open up this uh the hearing or hearing
schedule for today uh we have a number
of bills coming up which are early bills
so we will have to get right on top if I
do have a couple announcements first uh
representative cascadden was was kind
enough to bring in a sunshine fun jar
which is now in the
outer office there uh that's of course
is our coffee fund if you care to drink
coffee here that we make in in that room
uh you're welcome to put a buck or two
in it and help us get going and uh we
will talk a little bit more about this
at a later date is find out who we're
going to put in charge of our Sunshine
fun
um other announcements there's going to
be a number of bills going on in the
next several days in which folks are
going to have to be in three different
places at the same time at least it's
happening with myself like tomorrow I
got to be in ways and means in the
Senate Finance in the house and issuing
talking about a bill here so I'm trying
to manage how I'm going to do that I
know that there are some folks doing
that even today
on the committee I will also have be out
of here at 11 o'clock today to introduce
a bill in finance so this we're going to
have to recognize people are going to
come and go here that's fine this is is
a hearing we will continue with our
hearings
um
hope everybody had a successful day
dealing with all the snow yesterday I
did I learned more about my snow blower
than I have read before
so
um
my back did as well so uh with that I'd
like to go ahead I'm going to be leaving
here in about 10 minutes I have another
meeting spec schedule at 9 15
representative cordelli will will take
over and and guide you through that
meeting so what I'd like to do is open
up the hearing at that schedule for nine
that's HB 487 establishing a New
Hampshire Farm to school reimbursement
program
good morning representative
good morning good to see you again
yes can you give me one second to get my
everything lined up on my little desk
here
it's gonna be good to be back in front
of you again
um you know that we brought this uh Bill
forward last year so I'm going to talk
about the reasons and the background
first and then um for those of you who
are new especially and then also will
address the changes in the bill at this
um at this time so representative can
you first introduce yourself name that's
a great idea yes thank you chairman for
getting back in the mode here yeah
exactly exactly
um I'm representative Alexis Simpson I'm
from the town of Exeter and I represent
Rockingham 33 Exeter New Market New
fields and stratum
this bill number 487 represents many
hours of dedicated time and energy from
stakeholders across the state over the
past number of years those in the
Agriculture and food sectors those in
the school of nutrition programs and
those community members who represent
the social infrastructure that makes our
local food economies Thrive many of
those who contributed to this bill will
be testifying this morning although the
snow has thrown off some of our plans
but there are plenty of people here who
will be able to answer the questions
that you have I'm sure
um any of you heard me introduce the
bill last year but I want to talk a
little bit um
to those who are new or maybe weren't
part of the school nutrition
subcommittee that met um in the year
between last term and this term
we were able to um myself and other
stakeholders in this bill were able to
talk to the Department of Education and
the Department of Agriculture and have
come up with a a somewhat different bill
this year
the farm to school program operates in
some schools across the state at this
moment so local food is nourishing our
children supporting local farmers and
strengthening the resiliency of our
supply chain in some communities across
the state the investment we're asking
the state legislature to make and the
state to make will make it possible for
schools and communities all over the
state to take advantage of the benefit
of local food for local schools
with this policy we can improve the
health and well-being of our children
improve the local economies and the
resiliency of our local food system
the department of education's office of
nutrition programs and services would
provide a monetary incentive to schools
who choose to direct more of their per
meal cash reimbursement funds from the
USDA towards purchases from New
Hampshire
this day would then encourage this
channeling of federal funds into the
local economy by awarding schools a
dollar for every three dollars spent on
food from our state the goal is for
local schools to be purchasing at least
10 percent of their food from local
farms all that money then gets returned
to our local economy where it continued
um I shared with this subcommittee last
year and we'll share again that um or
with the school nutrition subcommittee
last year and want to share again that
um there's another financial piece of
this which is the return on investment
that we get from investing in school
nutrition programs I know you're hearing
lots of school nutrition bills so you
may already know this but a study out of
the Rockefeller Institute has shown us
that for every dollar we invest in
school nutrition there's a two dollar
return on investment so this is a
fiscally responsible commitment from our
state should we choose to make it
foreign
by offering every school a reimbursement
of up to twelve hundred dollars we would
be investing in our children's health
and our local economies we can also
redirect 1.2 million federal dollars
into our local economy that will help us
build food system into infrastructure
that will make us resilient for the
future
our children's health and the health of
our farms and farming communities are
worth this investment
as a result of conversation and
important feedback that we received over
the past year about this local Farm to
Local Schools food reimbursement policy
we are only allowing for reimbursements
of local food grown in New Hampshire
we're also excluding liquid milk which
we realized would eat up the
reimbursements quickly for an item that
is most times already coming from our
region if not our state
liquid milk also gets mixed together
across from with milk from New Hampshire
and other states across the region so
it's much harder to tell whether it
at the Department of Education we are
asking for one staff person to
administer the program the total cost of
the hire is estimated to be a hundred
and forty five thousand dollars and then
the technology to write the code to get
the program up and running will be a
one-time investment of fifty thousand
dollars
and we're asking the legislature to
commit six hundred thousand dollars to
the reimbursements themselves which will
go to the school nutrition programs
you'll notice on the um so
you'll notice on the bottom of your bail
that
the six hundred thousand dollars is not
on the bill
so I uh have an amendment which adds the
actual six hundred thousand dollars for
the reimbursement funds
um
into it's just a mistake in the original
bill that I didn't catch in time
um over Christmas so I'm going to pass
that around to you
um excuse me so when you have that
Amendment would you please hand all
those copies of the amendment up to the
clerk and we will distribute oh sure
sure I've also talked to representative
excuse me those will have to be
introduced by somebody on the committee
right and they can't look at them right
now they can yes they they can look at
them right now we will distribute those
I just want to make sure they all get it
sure for sure thank you
um and I've also spoken with
representative Tanner who is willing to
um work with me to bring the amendment
to the committee when you get to your
executive session
um do you want do you want them now or
after well then I would prefer then you
hand them all over to representative
Tanner great
if she's going to be involved with the
in closing although I do have a letter
that I have to introduce as well but um
a robust Farm to school program will
help strengthen New Hampshire's
agricultural sector and Regional food
security it'll also help New Hampshire
students understand the regional
agricultural Geographic social and
cultural aspects of our food system here
end of my testimony and I'll take
questions but I do my uh the food
service director at our um
Exeter Cooperative schools has asked me
to bring a letter from her she's not
able to be here
um but would like to introduce a letter
I can read that into the record or I can
give you a give the clerk a copy and
then she's also featured in The
Storybook so that
you'll get to see her picture as well no
not right this moment okay whatever
great
further
um no so that's all I have at this
moment I'm open to take your questions
at this moment thank you questions from
the committee
uh represent the dry
thank you Mr Vice chairman and thank you
for taking my question uh
um are you ready yeah I'm just getting
somebody so I can take notes yeah
um 1200 applies to if it applies to
every school it's kind of a big
difference between twelve hundred
dollars to the Cornish Elementary and
twelve hundred dollars to cure Sarge
High School is not prorated it's just a
flat fee yes that's correct
um and you're right it makes a
difference depending on the school it's
up to twelve hundred dollars
reimbursement so if each school would
get a third of what they spend so small
elementary schools may not spend thirty
six hundred dollars if they're not able
to but they would be reimbursed up to a
third of that
um and so in the past what we are one of
our challenges is
um a number of Staff people to deal with
a complicated system and so that was one
way that we thought would be
um easier for
um Administration yeah thank you that's
further questions from the committee
uh see none uh thank you representative
oh
uh representative pedernal
thank you Mr chair
um I just have a question about what
vegetables and fruits you think the
students will be acquiring from New
Hampshire from say the end of September
through the beginning of May
that is such a great question and I get
very excited about it having been a part
of the farm to school movement in my
town for over a decade
um I have a lot to say about that but I
actually think that you want to hear
from the director of the farm to school
program who will have much more detailed
information about that and we'll share
with you a calendar of um mostly
vegetables but for that time of year
thank you further questions uh see none
thank you very much thank you
good morning
um I apologize for my written remarks
I'm still without power so I didn't have
a printer so here I am before you
handwritten uh remarks in hand honorable
colleagues um for the record my name is
representative Megan Murray I represent
the towns of Milford and Amherst that's
Hillsboro District 37. I come to you
today in support
um as our communities have been without
power in large portions of the town as
crews are doggedly working to restore
power as a representative mother and
former educator seeking to restore the
balance of locally produced and sourced
Foods in our school lunchrooms I'm here
before you
New Hampshire is an amazing State many
of us as children and as adults being
with pride when we go to an
establishment featuring our Maple syrups
our berries our meats and produce and
various other value-added products
the same should be true for our children
in our schools
after speaking with myriads of families
in both communities whose Lifestyles
vary but their commitment to seeing
Foods grown and produced locally is here
I'm unified today with that desire our
districts children and nutrition
directors in both Milford and the
Amherst are featured in that storybook
that representative Simpson
brought before you
and um are excited to see that there
would be more locally procured
nutritionally dense foods at the tables
in the classrooms as a former educator
myself
the natural value in this effort extends
to learning and mentorship of a greater
understanding of our food system our
geography and also gives way to an
organic conversation about the
importance of knowing where our food
comes from
and by whom it is grown and that the
food supply resiliency is something that
we all must invest in together
I have the honor and frankly a bit of a
sorrow in talking with folks who have
for decades sought and worked hard to
reintroduce and implement the farm to
school program in our communities within
the San Diego Valley
but the time is right for our uh
students and our health and our local
economies to expand this program for the
farmers who work tirelessly to bring
foods not only
to our restaurants and grocery stores
but to our students whose nutrition will
no doubt benefit from the expansion of
there being local Farm to school
reimbursement monies available in our
school lunch programs across New
Hampshire
I urge the colleague my colleagues in
House Education to support this program
and the commitment to finding uh and
mentoring
excuse me funding and mentoring the
benefits of locally sourced nutrient
dense foods so that our children's
schools farmers and communities have the
best shot we can in thriving thank you
as a parent to three kids under 12 as a
former teacher and as Amherst and
milford's uh state representative for
Hillsboro District 37. thanks so much
thank you questions from the committee
uh representative Peter now
thank you Mr chair
um how many farmers do you have who are
interested in this program
that's a great question so we have heard
regionally in uh the Amherst Milford
area we have Farms all across whether
it's lull Farm Trombley Farm Brook uh
Brookdale Fruit Farm we have several in
the area who would love to participate
in this program and the school food and
nutrition Pro uh child directors have
have expressed that desire to continue
to look and Source Foods where they can
they do to the best of their ability try
to still get some of those Foods locally
sourced but it has become something that
they would like to see expanded
thank you
Rosa Tanner thank you and thank you for
taking my question what benefit do you
see or benefits do you see to the local
farmers from uh starting up this program
oh absolutely I I think there are many I
serve in environment and Agriculture and
aside from the additional exposure that
they get to having their food in the
schools it is also
um when we talk about locally sourced
economic resiliency I think that that's
part of the equation here right
um many times in classrooms where I had
been in
um the understanding of where their food
came from at lunch the children where
their food came from wasn't always
widely known and I think that this is
also part of that conversation as
representative Simpson mentioned to
connect children to their local food
sources
foreign
you Mr chair
um
in my experience
as a farmer for many years one of the
things that I've noticed is that
people don't really grasp where their
food is coming from unless they've
actually grown it touched it walked in
the field
built a relationship with the animals
they're raising how exactly would the
students be developing a greater
understanding of where their food comes
from if it's arriving to them just like
all their other food does
that's a great question I think some of
our folks at the farm to school program
will talk about like the food of the
month club that is also integrated with
that but in addition I think there's
also a natural opportunity for teachers
though it does not mandate any sort of
instructional curriculum I think it
gives a great opportunity for that to be
woven into the curriculum whether it's
geography whether it's talking about
those farms and where they are in their
communities and those types of food I
think that natural connection is there
representative Belcher
thank you Mr chair
um well first I'd like to say that I I
love the idea of incentivizing local
farms I think that's great but I do have
one significant concern that I hope you
can speak to a little bit here in this
um what is the reason
um in this bill that we would
um limit it to only schools
participating in the national school
lunch program and only to the guidelines
put forth by the USDA which which rely
heavily on the now widely discredited
so if I if I some of the folks behind me
will speak to some of that but some of
it is a requirement regarding uh the
funding and the sources of which that
that income comes from but I will
certainly let folks behind me speak to
that in Greater detail I do understand
it's complicated but I appreciate the
question thank you
representative Woodcock did you have a
question
thank you uh with the chairman good
morning representative how you doing
good to see you
um last year when the tortillas are
going to bill was introduced initially
uh secretary Jasper was here and he
spoke with favor of the bill you know he
still supports this bill
I believe that um the concept is
something that he is really interested
in seeing he has he had come before my
committee and actually spoke about
similar um efforts that um their work is
is interested in continuing to pursue so
uh though I don't want to speak for the
commissioner because I am not the
commissioner
um it has been something that he had
spoken in favor of before thank you
thank you Mr chairman
uh further questions
see none thank you very much
representative for testifying and I'll
I'll make copies and submit my uh
testimony for the record thank you
good morning for the record I'm
representative hope Damon Sullivan
District 8 the towns of Acworth Langdon
lemster gosh in Washington Springfield
San P coyton and Claremont I think I
said all nine
I'm stepping back from my role on this
committee and into my career as a
dietitian and diabetes educator and I
vigorously support this bill
local food tastes better
in blind taste tests if you give people
a fresh local carrot at an ordinary
grocery store carrot
they will tell you that the fresh local
one is sweeter and more yummy
my anecdotal experience of that I'm also
a significant vegetable Gardener not at
all commercially just sort of sharing
through the neighborhood
and one of our neighbors twin daughters
when she was seven pulled a carrot from
our garden
brushed it off not afraid of dirt took a
bite and looked at her mom and said her
carrots taste way better than your
carrots
that's not unique and children will eat
healthy good food if it tastes good to
them
so I vigorously support the idea of
local
I think it is critical that we support
our farmers and this is an excellent way
to do that
I think it was representative pedernal
who asked how many farmers are involved
or engaged in this possibility
since reading this bill a couple days
ago I reached out to three farmers in
Sullivan County they all
were very very interested they were not
aware of the possibility and would
indeed have fresh posts available in
some cases into November and then again
starting in May there's a lot of growing
that's happening in tunnels
those arched plastic looking things that
you see in the landscape where we're
extending the growing season a lot in
New Hampshire and the productivity is
good
um or apples
Apple's store really well we have lots
of apple farms in New Hampshire
and we are serving kids apples that come
from Washington State routinely I don't
think that makes any sense
honestly I want to just speak to the
statement about the basis of the food
pyramid
I've been a dietitian for 40 something
years no matter what structure is
outlined to Define good nutrition
they all say more fruits more vegetables
lean proteins this fits perfectly with
that thank you for your time
thank you questions
representative Belcher thank you again
Mr chair
um just to pick your brain a bit as a
dietitian because I obviously don't know
as much about that topic
um during our introduction to the USDA
that we went through a couple of weeks
ago and the requirements if I recall
the USDA requires that all of all
calories half of them must come from
carbohydrates and it also prohibits milk
with a fat content of more than one
percent in schools that are
participating if you can you speak to
the to the quality of that and if we
really want to be subjecting ourselves
to Federal requirements that feed our
sorry happy to try to answer
two parts really that are kind of
different
so uh working in reverse the question of
non-fat or lower fat dairy products
there's an enormous controversy in the
field of nutrition on that topic
and you can find credible research and
perspective on both sides
I personally think the weight of the
evidence still continues to support
less fat dairy products because the fat
that cinderic products is saturated fat
which there is Decades of evidence
but food preferences that people develop
when they're children
to a considerable degree last well into
adulthood unless somebody makes a
concerted effort to change
so if children learn to enjoy what we
believe is healthier for them that will
probably serve them well for the rest of
their lives
I would have a note that this bill
exempts fluid milk so that consideration
doesn't really fit here
and then refresh my memory what was your
first part
um oh the carbohydrate sorry spring
cramp for a second
just a quick layer basis because I
learned in my career very often that
people perceive carbohydrate containing
food so much more narrowly than is
accurate
everything that comes from the ground
everything that was originally a plant
is a carbohydrate with the exception of
vegetable oils pressed from corn or
sunflower seeds or whatever so in other
words if the food item didn't come from
an animal a chicken or a fish it has
carbohydrate fruits and veggies are
carbs oatmeal is a carb
legumes we are growing beans in New
Hampshire now dry beans like before
black bean soup for hummus things like
that
so I think when we look at the
recommendation of how much the diet
should come from carb the quality of the
carb the sources of the carb mix is much
difference as the amount that is
recommended I certainly wouldn't be
recommending that anybody get 50 of
their energy intake their calories from
white bread
or any bread for that matter but
carb is the energy fuel source that
muscles and the brain and other organs
use most efficiently most effectively I
hope that's helpful
yes thank you for the questions
see none thank you very much
representative thank you
with New Hampshire Solutions
speak on skin deeper
um
what we see is that you know our what we
advocate for is feeding children who
don't normally have access to healthy
affordable food and what we see with the
farm to school bill is that on average
there's a nine percent increase in
participation in school meals when
um Farm to school is implemented that 90
that nine percent means that children
who might not normally eat breakfast or
lunch in school are now eating breakfast
or lunch at school getting a balanced
diet and getting those calories that
they need that they might not be
receiving at home
um it also is great for the economy as
you've heard I don't think I need to
cover that again but there is a great
return on investment for local farmers
and for the school district
those food service programs run as a
business and they are better able to
feed more kids when they have more
participation so again going back to
that nine percent increase it means that
more there's more dollars for Food
Service
um programs to pay more money to their
staff to maybe purchase more local food
using other dollars because of the
increase in participation and
um
and also you know being able to give
back to their community and have that
return on investment back into the
community
see none thank you very much for being
here
Philip Brown
good morning my name is Phil Brown I'm a
retired Concord High School science
teacher I retired in 2009
and I'm here to speak in support of
House Bill 487 FN don't don't quite know
what the FN stands for but but that's
beside the point
um
this is January 23rd
five days and 37 years ago
Krista McAuliffe got in the spacecraft
Challenger
she was to be the first civilian in this
case teacher launched in to space safely
the day before
the lunch
Morton thiacal Engineers out in in Utah
pleaded
begged
could jehold tried anything to get the
NASA administrators not to Launch
the data supported the fact that if the
temperatures dropped below 50 degrees
there was a danger that the O-rings
and the shuttle would this would be
would be destroyed
data today also speaks to the reason why
we as a society need to not only support
current farmers
but also the farmers of the future our
children right
I'm also on the education and Outreach
committee for Nova New Hampshire and my
colleagues onofa will be speaking to why
farmers will benefit
but I want to speak to the data that
supports why we should be doing this and
I gave a document to representative Ford
to pass around and if you would just
turn in your document to this page right
here this second side of the first sheet
looks like this on the front side
if you could just proceed I don't know
if everyone has a copy of that yet so oh
just I have I have one extra does
everyone
yeah does everybody have a copy
just I have one extra yeah it's okay go
ahead oh okay so if you look on the back
side of that first sheet
the national oceanographic and
Atmospheric Administration keeps track
every year of how many billion dollar
disasters
have occurred
it would be difficult for anybody in
this room to not recognize that that we
have different kinds of meteorological
events happening in our society we have
floods we have wind storms and and the
number is increasing every year
if you look where I've highlighted in
red the top table on that sheet
represents the 20 years from 1980 to
1999.
and in those 20 years there were 82
billion dollar disasters 20 years 82
billion dollar disasters and the cost to
society was around 480 billion dollars
for those disasters if you look at the
second table down highlighted in red at
the bottom
that represents the year's
2017-2022 five years not 20.
86 billion dollar disasters to the tune
of roughly 750 billion dollars
those numbers are going to continue to
increase
we are in a perilous situation here in
New Hampshire because we produce
probably around three to four percent of
our food and State
some of you probably remember during the
the early days of the pandemic that
there were empty shelves
we need to do anything and everything
that we can to support local farming
Nova New Hampshire many of us and other
people in the state believe that by 2030
the state should be producing 30 percent
of its food in state
thirty percent three to four percent now
thirty percent by Twenty Thirty our
surrounding states like Vermont Maine
and Massachusetts even produce roughly
10 to 12 percent of their food currently
so the data speaks to the fact that we
need to truly do anything and everything
that we can to support farming and
gardening restorative sustainable
farming and gardening the state over the
next couple of decades to not only
ensure the survival of our children but
also of the other life forms that make
New Hampshire such a a mecca for
vacation and tourism
so that's what I would like to speak to
the last page here and I I would I would
welcome any and all of you
to take a trip up to Blossom Hill
Cemetery where Krista has been entombed
and enshrined and the Epitaph on her
tombstone written by her husband Stephen
the last the last two lines you can look
on it's kind of hard to see in fact I
have to put my spectacles on to be able
to read it
it says
she tried to protect our spaceship earth
she taught her children
to do the same
please support house bill 487. thank you
questions from the committee
representative Belcher
thank you Mr chair
um thank you for your testimony um I
certainly agree with the concept of
trying to increase uh the amount of food
that we produce here in New Hampshire
um but I'm wondering about your
testimony based on the idea of utilizing
um what's it called now sustainable and
restorative practices does that mean
um without or with minimal use of of
fertilizers and such
yes it does
quick follow-up please thank you just
um do you have a concept of how much of
New Hampshire land might have to become
Farmland to produce 30 of the food that
we consume utilizing sustainable methods
that I do not know however
if you have a lawn in front of your
house or anywhere around your house or
you have community garden space
available to you you as an individual or
as a family can be growing on that space
restoratively and sustainably building
up carbon in the soil over time which
will help combat the buildup of carbon
dioxide in our atmosphere just as a
point of information 1986 when that
precious woman was lost was the first
year that the atmospheric carbon levels
exceeded those levels which had been
historically present for forty Thousand
Years thank you very much thank you see
no further questions thank you for your
testimony if somebody want this copy uh
we'll get copies for everybody thank you
all right thank you next is uh
delicious is it champagne of say the
children it's definitely Deli okay thank
you and mother did that maybe just
everybody if we could try and keep
comments and questions to the Bill thank
you good morning everybody first of all
thank you for your service I can't
believe the amount of work you put into
this and it does not go unnoticed by
many of us so thank you my name is Deli
champagne and I work for Save the
Children Action Network there are two
campaigns that we really follow in New
Hampshire
or access to early childhood education
and access to proper nutrition
we have high school clubs we call them
scan clubs I have four in the state of
New Hampshire and they join the club not
because they want to advocate for better
access to early childhood education they
join the scan clubs because they want to
talk about nutrition and they want to
talk about their own nutrition and the
nutrition of their classmates
so I have some testimony here from the
president of the Concord High School
scan Club
you may have seen the company monitor
did an article about her front page a
few weeks ago she did a major fundraiser
and food drive for the local schools to
put better Foods in their pantries she's
really passionate about this she was
going to speak before you but her final
that was yesterday got moved to today at
nine o'clock so ideally wouldn't it be
great if you guys could actually meet in
schools and talk to the students my
favorite expression is nothing about us
without us how can we make decisions
about look at shaking her head how can
we make these decisions about students
without hearing from them so I'm going
to urge you to talk to the students
because in my work with these students
what I'm hearing
basically is they're asking can you get
rid of the junk that's in our cafeteria
we don't want pizza burgers and french
fries anymore I was with Alex at school
one day and someone walked by with a
tray of food and the oranges were in a
plastic container where you rip the
cover off
and she said heaven forbid they give us
a real orange
so they have a voice and they want to be
heard and they want you to know that
they want better quality food and they
want to support their Farmers my scan
Club in Pembroke is full of of students
that are very passionate about this
issue I met with them and they want to
go to elementary schools and they want
to educate young students about what
it's actually like to peel a banana
because we know some students don't even
know how to do that they don't know that
fruit and vegetables come from the
ground they think they come from cans or
plastic containers so I just want you to
know that students are passionate about
this they want you to care about their
food choices and unfortunately they
can't be here right now to tell you that
because they have finals and other
things and they're applying for colleges
so I want to be the voice for those
students and I ask you to please talk to
them please let them tell you what they
need and what they want we at scan and
adamantly support this bill so I would
appreciate you voting yes on House Bill
487. thank you questions
see none thank you very much for your
testimony
red there we go good morning my name is
Stacy purslow I am with the New
Hampshire Farm to school program and I
work out of the University of New
Hampshire sustainability Institute
I'm not here to take a position on the
bill but to provide some information
about Farm to school and farm to school
in New Hampshire
Farm to school enriches the connection
communities have with fresh healthy food
and local food producers by changing
food purchasing and education practices
at schools and early care and education
sites
Farm School Works in three areas
procurement local foods are purchased
promoted and served in the cafeteria as
a snack or in a classroom taste test
purchases support local farmers and
producers
education students participate in
education activities related to
agriculture food health and nutrition
School Gardens students engage in
Hands-On experiential learning through
gardening Gardens are wonderful places
to teach science math and the Arts
New Hampshire Farm to school started as
an idea from an organization called the
New Hampshire Coalition for sustaining
agriculture
a grant launched the program in 2003.
the UNH sustainability Institute has
been the home of New Hampshire Farm to
school since then
over the years New Hampshire Farm to
schools develop programs like New
Hampshire Harvest of the month the
indigenous New Hampshire Harvest
calendar hosted State conferences
offered various workshops and webinars
to educate Educators School Food Service
farmers and Fishers
developed a state and Regional Farm to
school network and more
Farm school programs exist in every
state and are connected through the
national Farm to school network as well
as to the USDA Farm to school program
many schools in New Hampshire
participate in farm to school already
they may have a garden program purchase
Local Foods or utilize programs like New
Hampshire Harvest of the month
Farm to school continues to grow year
after year
New Hampshire we also have a New
Hampshire school and youth Garden
Network made up of partner organizations
like UNH Cooperative Extension which
includes 4-H and the Master Gardeners
Milford New Hampshire Cornucopia project
which is based in the conval school
district U.S fish and wildlife New
Hampshire AG in the class grow Nashua
and others we provide resources and
professional development opportunities
to Educators across the state
next week we're offering offering a
webinar on classroom Hydroponics it's
one of six webinars being offered this
winter and spring
last summer New Hampshire Farm to school
partnered with New Hampshire hunger
Solutions and the New Hampshire
Department of Agriculture to submit a
proposal to receive funds for New
Hampshire through the local food for
school's Cooperative agreement from
usda's agriculture marketing service
the federal government made available to
each state funds to support schools
buying local food as part of coveted
relief and supply chain issues that
schools are experiencing
These funds close to five hundred and
seventy thousand dollars are to be used
to buy local food are targeted at the
highest needs schools in the state and
need to be expended by next fall
this opportunity we have will jump start
the New Hampshire local food for local
schools reimbursement program by
allowing schools to begin or reinforce
relationships between the schools and
local producers food hubs and Fishers
and will help farmers and producers
understand product need and demand by
schools which will Aid in crop and
Market planning in subsequent years
they will be in a better position to
meet the needs of schools
incentive programs like these that many
other states have already implemented
including Maine New York and Vermont
have been successful in shifting School
food funds to support local agriculture
which in turn support our local economy
and provide New Hampshire students
access to fresher tastier unprocessed
Foods
thank you
thank you and if that's written
testimony perhaps you could give it when
you're finished passing around to our
clerk for the record thank you very much
any questions from the committee uh
representative try thank you Mr rice
chairman thank you it sounds like you
have a pretty robust program right now
how would this interact with you is
there duplication or it just sounds like
a lot of what this hopes to do is
already be done yeah so New Hampshire
Farm to school will help schools
implement this reimbursement program we
can and we already have some resources
developed that will help students
understand where their food comes from
like the New Hampshire Harvest of the
month program which has classroom and
cafeteria resources as well as things
that kids can take home
and so we do have the resources within
my department as and with many other
partners across the state that would
help the Department of Education make it
a successful program
thank you
further questions
oh representative woodcock
hey chairman Cardiology
thank you for coming uh just to help me
out could you go back and uh clarify for
me your uh mention of the federal court
relief funding and the time frame on
that please sure so uh we had to apply
for it
um last summer so this Cooperative
agreement the federal government made
funds available to every state that's
based on you know student population
um and so we had to submit an
application of how we were going to
expend those funds and so the plan was
approved by the federal government and
it's going through our New Hampshire
Department of Agriculture and I I want
to say it needs to get executive Council
approval
um so I'm hoping to hear some more
information about that this month
because it's a short timeline to have to
spend this money by next fall so
um it's it's there but I think it needs
to go through some other stuff before we
actually have access to it
see no further questions thank you very
much for being here thank you
oh thank you for allowing me to speak
today
hmm
my name is Jane Jonas and together with
my wife Marilyn we own and operate
Hungry Bear Farm in Wilton and Mason New
Hampshire to we have been growing high
quality produce two or above organic
standards for our community going on 14
years now
we used to vent at many area farmers
markets
but for the past seven or eight years
we've mostly sold through our spring and
Main season csas about 30 weeks per year
we have a little experience selling to
schools but if given the opportunity
would probably choose to do so
I can tell you without a doubt that our
produce has been enjoyed by many people
over these years and surprisingly
especially by children and kids
one of the greatest Joys I encountered
during our CSA months is to witness the
excitement small children exhibit when
they come to pick up their CSA shares
every Tuesday at our farm seeing how
they often dive right into the carrots
snap peas sweet peppers cherry tomatoes
uh it's quite a joy to see
we also let them
make flowers and we talk with them and
your parents and
it's it's a very nice time pick up time
at our farm
most of them really love to participate
in the farm we are teaching these young
adults but great fresh organically grown
produce tastes like and where it comes
from and I believe they will not forget
it
if you give these kids this kind of
locally grown high quality food when
they are young they are more likely to
grow up and appreciate it they're also
more likely to grow up healthier too
with our current obesity crisis in this
and other countries
isn't it most important to provide this
kind of food to folks
according to a report from Johns Hopkins
University
Americans spend about 1.1 trillion
dollars each year on the purchasing of
food
we also spend roughly the same amount on
treating diet related diseases like
hypertension cancer and diabetes
most of the food people consume comes
from the so-called efficient industrial
agricultural sector
well
It Isn't So efficient if one considers
the externalized costs the big
agribusiness companies are allowed to
get away with
I'm talking about pollution greenhouse
gases
biodiversity loss the gutting of rural
communities increasing wealth disparity
and more
the big efficient industrial AG system
was crippled
by the covet pandemic starting in 2020
when supply chain issues arose
throughout the system
farmers were calling animals plowing
under produce when those markets were
disrupted I can assure you
there were no supply chain issues at
we had a record number of local folks
join our CSA in 2020 and sales have only
if given the chance and support Farms
like ours throughout New Hampshire and
New England
have proven to be reliable suppliers of
local fresh and high quality food
this is more of the kind
of Agriculture the world needs going
forward to combat climate chaos and feed
our communities
I urge you to support this bill that
would help begin to supply this type of
Health giving food to our young students
throughout the New Hampshire school
system
it is an extremely worthwhile investment
in our Collective future and by the way
don't our young folks deserve it
thank you
any questions
see none thank you very much for being
here this morning thank you uh next I'm
not sure the first name but I think the
can you hear me okay all right great yes
we can thank you
hello my name is Nikki cold and I am the
operations director at Nova New
Hampshire the Northeast organic farming
Association of New Hampshire
we help people build local just and
sustainable Food Systems by actively
promoting organic regenerative
ecologically sound farming gardening
eating and land care practices for
Healthy Communities as a member of the
New Hampshire Farm to school network and
a Statewide Association representing New
Hampshire Farmers gardeners and eaters
know that New Hampshire is in strong
support of HB 487 FM the local food 4
Local Schools reimbursement program
not only will the local food for local
schools reimbursement program increase
food security and resilience in New
Hampshire it will improve Farm viability
by channeling 1.8 million dollars into
the state's Farm and Food economy
annually it will provide New Hampshire
students with access to fresher nutrient
dense foods it will help students learn
about local and seasonal foods and it
will allow New Hampshire's public
schools to receive financial
reimbursement for one dollar out of
every three dollars spent on food
purchase from New Hampshire producers
and Fishers
why is this program necessary in
addition to the health benefits for
children the bill will help improve our
local economy by keeping federal dollars
in New Hampshire and it will increase
business and resilience for Granite
State farmers producers and Fishers
it will also provide students with a
deeper understanding of where their food
comes from and what professional
opportunities exist in New Hampshire's
Farm and Food economy
all of this is critical because today
only about six percent of food consumed
in New Hampshire is produced here
over the last three years we've seen how
a largely import-based food economy can
be affected by external conditions
leading to food insecurity Supply chains
are still being impacted by the ripple
effect of the pandemic climate change
and Market consolidation
the local food for local schools
reimbursement program will increase food
Security in New Hampshire decrease our
Reliance on food imports and help ensure
that our state remains resilient in the
face of ongoing stressors impacting our
national and Global Food Systems
and finally this bill is a proven model
and is based on similar legislation in
New York and Vermont as some of our
colleagues have stated
and also to quote from Alexandria
Grappone a senior at Concord High School
who shared her story in the local food
for local schools stories of impact
which I believe you all have and who
Deli mentioned as well
Alexandria says many students depend on
School meals as their guaranteed meal of
the day so making sure it is delicious
and nutritious is crucial the local food
for local schools reimbursement program
will give schools increased funds to
purchase fresh local and nutritious
produce it will also help build
relationships between local farms and
schools to allow students to learn about
agriculture where to find fresh produce
and the benefits of having a nutritious
diet
with over 75 of the nearly 150 schools
that participate in New Hampshire Farm
to school programming already serving
local food New Hampshire has a strong
foundation in place for successfully
implementing this critical bill
and we hope you'll join New Hampshire's
Farmers students parents Educators and
food service providers by passing the
local food for local schools
reimbursement program through thank you
for your time thank you very much other
our questions from the committee
thank you very much thank you David
Trumbull
foreign
welcome good morning
um my name is David Trumbull I live in
the town of where I'm a vegetable farmer
I've been a farmer for over 40 years
I've run my own farm for the last 37
years certified organic I'm also the
manager of a multi-farm CSA there's six
Organic Farms that provide food to about
250 families we grow about three acres
of produce and provide seedlings to
about 400 families on our farm over the
years we've sold the stores throughout
the state csas in down to the Boston
Market when our children were younger we
got involved in the schools and
developed relationships there doing
farmer to the school programs in the
elementary school building raised beds
and growing food at the middle school
that went to the food pantry and
appearing at days when they invite
people from the community to come in and
talk about different careers there's
been really good testimony talking about
the value of the quality of local food
for the students so I won't go into that
and also the value to the state economy
of the almost 2 million dollars a year
but I would just like to emphasize as a
farmer two points first is why would
farmers want to participate in this
program and the reason is this is that
farmers have to make a living and
they're looking for markets that will
cover the cost of their production we
have not sold produce to our local
school because it would not work work
out economically the price that they
could pay just would not match our cost
of production as local small-scale
farmers they can buy food off the truck
where they buy all the rest of their
food at a cheaper rate with this bill
was going to be an economic incentive
that gives the school some extra money
so that they can then deal with the
local farmers meaning that the schools
will get the produce and the farmers
will be able to get paid their a price
that will match their cost of production
so if you pass this bill using this
funds you will help the farmers go find
that extra market right now they may
have a few Acres of vegetables and have
various farmers markets and other
outlets one more Market can really make
a big difference to that farm in terms
of that Farm's viability you know this
would give them that opportunity to
participate the second thing is the
building relationships in the community
once you get a farm involved in bringing
in produce to the school they're going
to now start showing up at the school
they'll be making deliveries and they'll
start building relationships and when
the school says well we want to have a
program involving something to do with
agriculture they'll say we already have
a farmer we're working with so they'll
call that farmer in say will you come in
and work with our kindergarten class
bring in pots fill them up with plant
seeds do something farmer to school
program will you help us make a garden
up behind our school you'll build these
relationships so this bill is not just
about buying food it's about building
relationships and I I would as a farmer
I would offer it my support for those
reasons thank you thank you very much
are there any questions from the
committee
I do have one question for you I'm not
yes I have to hook that fast uh and
maybe you can help me
um and maybe this question was asked
during the time that I wasn't here when
I was out at another meeting but uh
question regarding where I live in
Haverhill that's right in the
Connecticut River much of the land which
we have in haverhills least by farms in
Vermont due to statutory regulations
Vermont finds it very good to be able to
do that so we have material our our
crops which are perhaps grown but
process across the river and we see that
as one community
um I know the same thing when I go
shopping at Hannaford it says local on
it and the potatoes from Arista County
so in order to make this work do we have
to really better Define the word local
there are legal definitions of what
local means I think for New Hampshire it
means it has to be produced in the state
some people in marketing terms will say
anything grown within 50 miles like
it'll be Farm stands to say we resource
from farms within a 50-mile radius and
that sort of thing and you're in the
position there on the Connecticut River
Valley we have some of the best Farmland
in the entire country
so but maybe you maybe this bill could
be amended to make a situation like
yours where you're right on the border
if there are Vermont Farms producing a
lot of carrots that they could sell to
your school if there's no other carrot
grower in town but it could also maybe
encourage some local farmers in your
area to say wow okay there's a potential
Market there let's see if we can't get
into this
thank you very much you're welcome sir
thank you for the questions
thank you
going on to the next person is Megan
Hoskins
welcome thank you
chairman distinguished members of the
committee thank you for being here today
my name is Megan Hoskins I live in
Manchester
um I did submit a testimony online I
wasn't sure if I would have the courage
to testify today
um
but I am here
so my name is Megan Hoskins MSC I am a
field organizer for climate action New
Hampshire project of the league of
conservation voters I am here testifying
today as an individual as a citizen
um
all right uh would like to testify
support uh for House Bill 487 local food
and local schools reimbursement bill
that will provide funding for a
reimbursement program to incentivize
participating New Hampshire schools and
Food Service directors to purchase
locally grown and produce food for
breakfast and lunch Services as a
graduate from Antioch University New
England in Keene their Environmental
Studies program with a concentration in
advocacy for social justice and
sustainability I fully support this
legislation that will bring Farm Fresh
sustainable Local Foods to our schools
and the children teachers and staff who
fill those cafeterias
I believe that all students need good
nutrition to learn well the local food
and local schools reimbursement program
will boost youth health and wellness and
support the economic viability of New
Hampshire's Farms as you all have heard
from Farmers today
a state investment of six hundred
thousand dollars in the local food for
local school reimbursement program
combined with the 1.2 million dollars in
federal monies participating New
Hampshire schools receive as part of the
funding for the national school lunch
program School breakfast program and the
fresh fruit and vegetable program will
inject 1.8 million dollars into New
Hampshire's agricultural economy
participating schools will be reimbursed
a dollar for every three dollars spent
on purchases from New Hampshire
producers and Fishers with a
reimbursement cap of twelve hundred
dollars per School per school year
purchase foods will be required to meet
qualifying criteria to be eligible for
reimbursement eligible Foods include
Dairy fruits vegetables beef poultry
eggs and pork sustainably caught fish
cider and maple syrup and can be
purchased directly from producers from
New Hampshire or Regional food hubs or
through conventional Distributors all
food purchased with will require proof
of origin on submitted invoices
66 000 students in New Hampshire already
participate in farm to school activities
such as school garden programs nutrition
agriculture oral and cooking curriculums
the local food and local school
reimbursements program will bring Farm
to school learnings from the classroom
to the cafeteria and students who do not
have access to farm to school
programming will have the opportunity to
learn about the variety of fruits
vegetables and other products grown and
produce both locally and regionally
uh please support fresh local food in
our children's schools and fund the
local food for local schools
reimbursement program thank you thank
you very much are there questions from
thank you
um
regarding we we keep hearing about
vegetables and its roots and whatever
and I'm wondering do you know how much
we are accessing fish and animals meat
currently our schools with the farmers
that we have in the state
um I specifically do not know that
information but I imagine our friends at
maybe the Northeast organic farming
Association or the uh Monadnock Farm to
School Association I believe is another
one who could probably tell you a lot
more as well as the UNH
um sustainability Institute I believe
so I think there's a lot of places to
get that information
I think it's good that this bill
includes you know both Investments and
vegetables but also Dairy and you know
fruit uh meat and beef and poultry and
fish you know those are all important
you know
um nutritional needs so
um
all right so I'm not entirely sure how
much we're accessing now
um but I imagine that it would greatly
be boasted by this legislation thank you
very much for the questions represent
Belcher
thank you Mr chair
um there's a word I'm not clear on I
I've heard a number of times now
um the word justice is being used in
context I'm not familiar with such as I
think I heard food Justice can you can
you Lucid Define what that means in this
context
I'm sure so
um I think in this context it refers to
um Social Justice and
um quite frankly economic Justice in a
number of ways
um you know the way we fund schools here
in New Hampshire as we are all very
familiar with on this committee
um you know you know schools and towns
are left to do with what they can with
property taxes that they have and
low-income communities
do not get as much funding as wealthier
communities and so this bill would
address some of those issues by pretty
much leveling the playing field by
allowing schools and low-income
communities to use these monies the same
way that these schools and Wealthy
communities are able to use this money
thank you
further questions not seeing any hands
thank you very much thank you
this will conclude our hearing on 487 we
have no more pink cards so this hearing
is closed
the next hearing which we have in front
of us is HP 492 representative Tanner
is
I'll see if we can probably
put some right here he's pretty shallow
okay we're ready to go with 492. uh
representative Tanner is here she's
going to introduce her bill our bill our
our bill yes our bill representative
thank you uh for the record I'm
representative Linda Tanner I represent
Sullivan County uh District Five which
includes the two towns of Sunapee and
Springfield and we're very grateful for
all the snow up in our area it's white
gold to US
um
I I am introducing a bill that will
require the Department of Education to
provide us with education law books
um that are annotated and in uh last
term the first part of the last term
well I back up a little bit this is my
fourth term on the education committee
fifth term in the house and each of
those terms up until last term we were
supplied the education annotated laws
the first year of last term was very
chaotic with covid and whether we were
masked or whether we were here or not
here or whatever when we finally came
into and during that period of time we
did not receive this book and it it
greatly bothered me and so the second
year of the term I put in a bill
um to require the Department of
Education to provide us with this book
and why
um well I'm a trained my education is
all in in education I'm a retired
teacher and not a lawyer and it was very
intimidating when I first got on the
education committee although I really
wanted to be on the committee uh
intimidating with all the the lawyer
talk and trying to devise laws and and
knowing what was going on I I was very
frustrated when I first came to the
state house because after many years of
teaching and any of you that have been
in schools know that sometimes the rules
that are made at the state level
just don't fit with the schools when
they're put into into action so I was
very keen on you know changing some of
the laws and
um I found the book to be invaluable to
bring me up to speed it's annotated it
has the history of bills it has the
changes in bills over the years as well
as what the present Bill States
and so not having it during that first
part I I kind of said wow you know I
really really need to ensure for me for
all of us here that we have that sort of
resource we you know we have a box over
in the state house we have our little
file cabinet and we have a great
research assistant but she's dealing
with a lot of people and can't be
bothered on a regular basis with our
little questions about rules so it's
it's one of our resources I I think it's
necessary for us to do our job properly
and
um I know that rules are the laws are
online I've gone on Google several times
to find them but you don't find the
annotations and it isn't like you can
have an interest in for example School
nutrition and look it up in the mid
various laws that it appears in the law
books so
I feel the book is really important so
what happened to my bill well it went
out of this committee unanimously
because I think everyone particularly
incumbents knew how valuable sometimes
you don't realize what you don't have
so uh but it went out of committee
unanimously went into the Senate and
presenting it and of course Senator have
their their offices and they have their
researchers and you know they they're
set up in a different
um
framework than we are as far as
resources are concerned and so I was
explaining trying to explain to them the
same thing I'm explaining to you why I
think they're necessary and um
the person from OLS uh came to to
testify against my bill and basically
his uh testimony said that the publisher
was not going to publish the that he had
heard that the publisher was not going
to publish the book again and that
um not only that but you know it's
online and everybody can see that and
you know ask OLS they have their
resource people and we'd be just fine
without it so the Senate
um despite my
urgings
um tabled it and so it didn't go through
so I was kind of um
ready this year to put in the same bill
uh thinking that well maybe you know
we'd get the the book I spent some time
researching with the publisher uh
Thompson Reuters and also Westfall and
to try to find out where exactly it was
being published where it was being
printed because the first part of the
book has governor sununu in it I I knew
that that probably wasn't something that
was put in uh at a national printer and
I came up that ends every place I went I
came up dead ends so come into
um session this year into our committee
and happened to cruise to the back of
the room to speak to our attorney from
the Department of Education who does a
wonderful job for us uh really and um
there she is with a green book a brand
new uh annotated
education law so as you probably
understand from some of the in-house
jokes that we've had about asking when
we're going to get our book
um it was published this year and it was
printed this year
um
and it isn't available to us and I think
that's a real shame
you'll note that on the bill it has a
financial note with it I spoke to my
local superintendent because one of the
things that I think is important and
should happen if it didn't was that all
the superintendents in the state should
get
the annotated education laws I mean how
are you going to follow laws unless you
really know what's happening and he
assured me that the state department
made available to them a flash drive or
however you want to call it um to with
all the um annotated bills on it I I'm
not sure it was annotated actually but
he said that the state department
provided him with that and told him that
if he wanted another one for his
principles or whatever that it would
cost him a hundred dollars a piece
which seems kind of steep for a flash
drive but
um I'm assuming that's the cost for the
book as well it's about a hundred
dollars a book and yet the fiscal note
um which you may be able to ask other
people that have developed that physical
note
um estimates fifty four thousand dollars
and I figure if there's 20 of us and 100
a book and maybe throw in a few extras
um you know it's probably less than five
thousand dollars so
um I kind of questioned the the amount
of money although maybe it's shipping
costs or whatever
so anyway
um that's my story I've given you
written testimony
um it was three hole punch so my margins
are kind of wide and you'll have to play
like teacher and try to figure out in
the context what the word is
um I always love those and I'm open for
any questions thank you very much
representative Tanner uh before we go
into questions I just want to impart
some information here
I've spoken with the ranking
representative here and myself we both
agree this bill needs to move forward
and this is echoing what this committee
did in previous years unanimously
and if we want to move forward and if we
want to exec that bill immediately we
have to do that today
and by doing so we can get it and we
don't have to get it into the calendar
because the public is hearing us that we
may be executing this bill today
and with that we can get it in the
calendar for action on the next session
which would be next week
and so I would encourage all committee
members here to afford US the time to
have a quick executive session so we can
move this thing forward
so are there any questions
yes representative Wright thank you Mr
chairman thank you representative Tanner
so just to be clear the online version
right now does not have the is not
annotated
uh right and when you go when you go
online at least and I'm not a computer
expert so maybe I'm totally missing
something but when you go online
uh you can't put in like I said
nutrition like I've spent hours kind of
going to Chapters uh on a particular
subject that I was interested in and
finding references from one particular
law to another law and be able to look
up that
um whereas when I've gone online you
know I have to put in like 194 colon 5
subsection
and then that's what I see so
um
and plus when I need it sometimes is
when we're talking we're having bills
coming in and you'll see references
within the bill
uh for different
laws and all of a sudden I want to say
oh well what was that or even
representative Bruno will grab my book
and say let me look that up
um and it's right there versus going on
the computer hoping that the legislative
internet's up and running fast and
getting to that and then then coming
down so a book in hand and maybe it's
old school but a book in hand is what I
like I'm going to make another comment
here
this is not old school this is current
school when we talked in previous years
about the delivery of an adequate
education and we were wanting to find
out what happened in Londonderry case
the Claremont decisions it's not there
online you will not find that that
enters into our discussion and our
decision making and we need these Yellow
Green books light green yes we need the
Green books
further just questions yes represent
luno
I'll break a rule would you believe
I've been uh I've been also caught
um snooping through uh chairman Ladd's
law book as well okay yeah and all the
sticky notes and everything so yes well
looking for things
we borrowed it yes together represent
Woodcock
um representative because you know I
don't lost anyhow when it comes to this
trying to get it on I can't get it on my
flip phone by the way in case you're
interested
um uh the question is is this law going
to be uh annual uh every biennium to be
or just singly for this uh issue this
session I believe it's written that they
are required in French biennium
to present us with that well thank you
thank you Mr chairman I want to clarify
one more thing if we don't exec this
bill in the next eight minutes we will
not be executing this bill
foreign
McDonald thank you Mr chair and thank
you for bringing this forward my
question you mentioned the fiscal note
on the back it says that the bill would
be for the cost of 54 000 would be for
424 members of the House and Senate yet
the title of the bill says it would just
be for those on education committees so
could you clarify which is which
um
well
I didn't didn't realize that uh they
thought everybody in the state house
should have a book
um it the bill isn't the intent of the
bill my intent of the bill is just for
the education committee for the House
and Senate education committee and I
thought that was in the bill but if it
isn't yeah it's just the fiscal note at
the bottom says otherwise but all right
thank you yep further questions
yes
yeah I'm concerned about the fiscal note
also because that seems like
um
I guess I try to put this in a question
maybe this would be more appropriate for
the exact if I had something to say
statement wise about getting this
changed because
it'll go to finance this is a early bill
with a financial note we're looking at
the policy matters here in terms of the
physical note that will be the uh
responsibility of division two Finance
when they receive this bill
so you you know that this question of
course will be brought up at that time
further questions representative thank
you Mr chair thank you Linda for
bringing our representative Tanner for
bringing this forward I know from your
mentoring how valuable this book would
be if I had it
um and I think that the fiscal note took
the last line of the bill that a member
of the House Representatives or Senate
May request and they
budgeted as if the entire House and
Senate are going to request it which
seems extremely improbable so it's
clearly a very generous fiscal note
yes and I I would really like this bill
exec today because even if it goes
through today it means we'll get a book
starting the next time any more pink
hearts for this bill okay I'm closing
this hearing
okay we will go into executive session
on HB 492 I Look to represent myo to
make a motion please I would move that
we moved to ought to pass
492 as presented and I will second that
motion
so we have a motion on the floor to
OTP
492.
made by representative Miler and second
by representative Ladd is there any
discussion on this bill for the
discussion
not seeing any hands up in the air now
uh we'll wait for our clerk here to this
the first bill we've exec they're going
to have to get the paperwork out and do
this properly
the motion again is on 492 requiring the
Department of Education to provide the
House and Senate standing committees
responsible for Education with copies
and laws and rules relative to education
the motion's been made by representative
HP
and I
492. HB 492 requiring the Department of
Education to provide the House and
Senate standing committee's responsible
for Education with copies of the laws
and rules relative to education
foreign
representative cordelli
yes
representative leckis
representative Ford
yes
representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble
yes
representative pedernal yes
representative cortiello yes
representative Myler yes representative
Cornell
yes
representative Tanner yes
representative
representative Ellison yes
representative Woodcock yes
for representative Hall
yes
representative Balboni
representative cascad and yes
representative Damon yes
okay
so you kind of go back to the top now
and take my name I'm sorry
read the results 20 years zero Nays the
motion passes and this will well we'll
put it on consent if they allow us to
put an early bill with a financial note
on I'm going to try putting it on
consent and we'll get our hands slapped
if we have to but well all approval
consent
we will put it on consent
or whatever okay yeah thank you
thank you very much so we have a short
break here from three minutes
congratulations our first bill
excuse me did I did I mispronounce
the only one we're going to have a hard
time is 4 to Yellow
foreign
okay we're ready to go ahead with the
next bill to be heard this morning HB
437 relative to a reading assessment and
Intervention Program representative
cardelli welcome
uh thank you Mr chairman thank you
committee members uh for the record
representative Glenn cordelli
representing tuft and Borough Wolfeboro
and Ossipee in the beautiful Lakes
Region and it's a pleasure to present
this bill to you today
um I guess it was about four years ago I
was at a convention and heard one of the
keynote speakers uh indicate that um
back in the 1960s for black uh boys
could not go into a diner in Selma
Alabama
today they can go into that Diner but
they can't read the menu
that stuck with me
um and has helped me
decide to move forward with this
legislation many of you have seen the
nape scores recently uh showing a
massive three-point decline in eighth
grade reading nationally over the past
five years
in New Hampshire there's been an even
steeper decline
uh New Hampshire eighth grade
proficiency is 46 percent in English
um should
having a high school diploma in New
Hampshire mean that you can read and
write
since 2019 at least 26 states have
passed laws to improve literacy and
Implement what researchers have found
about how kids learn to read
as Frederick Douglass said once you
this legislation is based upon the
successful state literacy legislation
around the country and consult a
consultation with local and National
experts
um
it also follows on to initiatives uh
initiated by commissioner edelblood and
the department which will you will see
in the exhibits
what I'd like to do is go through the
legislation and point out the high
points to you I think the top sheets you
have in your packet that's volume one by
the way I'm just kidding
the top sheets are a highlighted version
of the legislation which I'll be
um section one
discusses the need for screening
assessment and intervention
you will see on uh lines at the top a
line seven on down and the requirement
for a universal screener for reading to
be used in all public schools in grades
uh any substantial deficiency
found
as a result of these screenings
would be the generation of an individual
a learning plan and intervention in
general education classes
I'll just note that I do have an
amendment that will be brought forward
which integrates further the uh three HP
337 dyslexia bill into this and you'll
note also that I've been contacted by
the
government relations director for
amplify which is the parent company of
the Dibble screening test and I have a
call with her this afternoon she wants
to discuss how they can support this
legislation
um so in lines 13 through 19 you'll see
about the development of an individual
reading plan uh where there is
intervention required and below that uh
I list the requirements of the
individual reading plan including goals
and benchmarks the services to be
provided the reading instruction
and I do mention at the bottom of the
page 30 lines 30 31
that the three queuing method of reading
instruction shall not be used and we'll
talk about three queuing a little bit
later
uh going on I think the second major
Point
um is that we want school parental and
Community involvement in this process if
we're going to improve literacy
um in the state of New Hampshire I think
uh all hands have to be on deck not just
the teachers in the classroom
so uh
you'll see that when there's a
deficiency discovered immediate parental
notification is required and that
notification would include the
requirement for uh the presentation of
strategies that parents can be used be
using to help their child improve in
foreign
major point
is annual reporting and that is on the
bottom toward the bottom of page two
um reporting would be required from each
district annually first to the
department and then to the legislature
and below that on the bottom of page two
and over on looks at me I guess it's
just on the bottom of page two you will
see the requirements for that reporting
so that we all can have an idea of how
literacy Improvement is working in the
state and to make sure it is working in
the state
uh if there is no meaningful progress
then there would be a referral made for
special education I do not require any
specific time for a special education
referral when we're talking about HB 337
there was some indication about
time frames and what
time frames are used in schools but I
did not specify anything in here because
I don't want to
over
categorize students into special net
um the fifth Point
um is uh on the middle of Page Three
um and this is a a departure from what
we have now uh there would be reading
Improvement Grants
um this is really paired with uh
highlight number seven you'll see later
but the reading Improvement Grants would
replace the third grade reading
differentiated Aid that we have now
these new grants would provide up to one
thousand dollars for each student with
deficiency
and as you know
um that's uh more than the current
differentiated aid plus differentiated
Aid is only provided when the student is
not free and reduced lunch special ed or
English language learner so I think this
will be quite a few more students that
would be eligible for the one thousand
dollar reading Improvement Grants
foreign
just down further on the page is uh
number six
which modifies the current literacy
statutes 189 of 53.
and what I've inserted here is the fact
that we need to provide instruction
based on measurable evidence-based
reading practices down below you'll see
I specifically mention what is termed
the science of reading
um the science of reading is based on
years of research into how students
learn to read and on the top of the next
page you'll see the main components
of the science of reading uh going on
from phonics to vocabulary and oral
language and we'll talk about science of
reading a little bit more and there is a
a document in your handout related in
depth to the science of reading
and the last
major bullet point is number seven the
repeal of the differentiated Aid statute
which is printed on your sheet for your
information
um
if I could go briefly through the
exhibits
um just to point out to you what what is
in there
um beach one is um
numbered um exhibit one Etc
exhibit one is
the result of a five-year investigation
by an education reporter into reading
instruction it's called sold a story and
is a series of eight I think it's eight
podcasts or
you can read the transcripts but it's
very informative
and it really details the failures of
current
reading instruction in many places based
on that three queuing technique that I
mentioned earlier and the move to the
science of reading
um
in particular I uh I recommend episodes
one five and six of of the podcasts
um
going further quickly
on the
flip side of that page exhibit two are
the um reading scores uh from nape uh
specifically for New Hampshire
number three is a uh disturbing
assessment of Nate results with uh
charts on reading scores around the
country
uh fourth is the uh
a paper called
excuse me academic recovery and risks
remain and that's from uh the Amplified
parent company of Dibbles did I
mentioned earlier
the fifth exhibit is New Hampshire
English language arts proficiency rates
by school
for 2017 to 2021
uh number six is the
uh explanation of the science of reading
um but again this is uh the science of
reading is uh now widely accepted across
the country and there's a great movement
toward this type of instruction
um there are
numerous states that have implemented
um I think it's 26 States since 2019
have implemented literacy legislation
mostly based on the movement to the
science of reading
um
and um I I think that we should follow
suit
um in that
document uh exhibit number seven talks
about the three queuing system
um
and as mentioned um in the testimony on
House Bill 377
um this method was popularized by a
number of
textbook and lectures
um
dating back several decades
um and the three queuing method involves
really just what it says cues readers
are looking at cues and those cues could
be
um looking at a picture in the text
um trying a word to see what makes sense
and even skipping a word to try and
figure out what that sentence says so a
lot of it is encouraging guessing on the
part of a reader one example that's
stuck in my mind from the podcast sold
the story was a middle school teacher
relaying how one of her students thought
that the text said that in 1939 Poland
they invited the Germans into their
country rather than invaded their
country
which um is considerable difference
uh exhibit 8 is the Scarborough's
reading rope which was created a couple
of years just to show the complexity of
reading and many of the strands you'll
see relate back to the science of
reading
number nine is a discussion of reading
legislation around the country
and number 10 follows on to that and
highlights uh the examine of examination
of what has been done in four states
um and um for anyone interested I also
have
um a chart
showing all 50 states and what has been
going on in in all 50 states that I'd be
um number 11 and 12 I had mentioned that
this follows on to initiatives from the
Department of Education number 11 is a
press release from last year about
um their coal their so-called leaning
into literacy program which talks about
training parents and Educators in the
science of reading
and number 12 is the program that has
been implemented the letters
courses that are available and the uh
goal is to train something like uh 9 000
people teachers and parents across the
state in the next few years in the
science of reading
and the final document is an article
written by a former Governor Jeb Bush of
Florida about
um the instruction into reading
um
I think we need to reverse the decline
in the reading abilities of our students
um
there are many components to this bill
the screening assessment intervention
involvement on the part of everybody and
the new reading Improvement Grants
so I ask your support in this bill and I
think that having a high school diploma
from New Hampshire should mean that you
can read and write and just let me close
with a quote from a teacher at the end
of the sold the stories
podcasts
where she discovered that her daughter
this was a teacher she discovered that
her daughter was having problems and
everyone thought that her daughter was
reading reading well in school that's
what she was told told
but her daughter came to her and said I
can't read
the teacher went on to say
this kid's sinking everywhere and
they're looking for our help
and it's on us
well right now it's on us and we have
the opportunity to impact the future of
many children in this state and really
the future of this state
so thank you very much for your
attention thank you very much
representative cordelli
um I'm going to ask one question that I
have to be out of here in a few minutes
to present and finance representative
cordelli on your bill on page one line
13 says each student who exhibits a
substantial deficiency in Reading
on page two line seven it says the
parent of any K through three student
who exhibits a deficiency in Reading
my question therefore is that you're
going to communicate with a parent
that there's a deficiency and of course
in my experience as a fourth grade
teacher
and as an administrator and a principal
an education all my life in the
elementary end that there are students
in grade three and earlier who have
these elements are components of reading
that you've mentioned whether it be
phonics or phonetic awareness whether it
be fluency vocabulary or comprehension
these third graders though have
vocabulary and comprehension but I gave
them against mcginnity test they would
show on a norm reference test high
achievement in the country yet they may
not have
that fanatic background that we speak of
in this bill
or awareness so what a Digraph is what a
diphthong is so my my con question to
you I guess is that should we have the
notification to apparent on page two
where it says a substantial deficiency
which is going to allow for the student
that's really reading well and
comprehending everything they read and
has a tremendous vocabulary but may not
be just in the expert in area phonics
so should we have similar language
between page one and page two
um I I think that might might be
appropriate
um but I think that if we move all of
the state into the science of reading
instruction
um that will help with the the phonics
component that you that you mentioned
also
um it's not going to happen overnight I
realize that
um and um
really leads into the question
um that we can talk about also
um is to this science of reading
research has been going on for a decade
or more why haven't there been why
hasn't there been the move to this type
of instruction until the past year or
two
um but you know we could discuss that an
hour or later also thank you very much
I'm going to open up the questions right
now representative have your hand up I'm
going to have to leave at this point in
time reps in my own would you take over
a second while I'm
representative Morrow has been chair of
this committee and uh so I asked I
should be back by
um
by about uh 11 15 hopefully
hopefully
one other thing we do not have any other
pink cards on this
are there any other pink cards for this
or is represent cordelli the only one
speaking this bill
sounds like he's the only one so we
thank you
representative thank you
thank you for taking my question I'm
wondering are there
materials uh out there
for parents who themselves can't read or
can't read well
so that they can you know in that
section where we're asking the parents
to be working with their students are
there materials that they can do
even when they're they have the same
issue
I I would think that through Adult Ed
programs through various other programs
but that could well be a side benefit to
this whole initiative
um is having parents realizing gee I
don't read so well either and maybe I
need to to brush up on my skills in that
area so that that could definitely be a
side benefit to this to this effort
thank you other other question
representative uh Tanner uh thank you
thank you for taking my question and I'm
I when I saw this bill I was kind of
worried of how it was going to affect
the other dyslexic uh testing bill that
we had 377 so be interested to talk with
you about that
um but I have a couple of questions
about this one one is you keep talking
about the science of reading and usually
what we're talking about when we're
talking about
initiating kind of testing and programs
like this we talk about best practices
um that leaves a little bit more open is
is there a reason that you keep pushing
the science of reading rather than best
practices
thank you for the question
um I think what his term the science of
reading does involve best practices it's
all evidence-based research that has
been gathered and uh all the states that
have an issued initiated programs in the
past several years
um as well as many others are moving to
the science of reading and um
I'll try and
remember to send out this this chart of
all 50 states uh to you as a matter of
fact in many states that have
implemented literacy programs they are
holding back children from going into
the fourth grade
um who if they are not proficient in
Reading I I didn't go that direction in
this bill but a number of states are
doing that and just allowing for
exemptions
um for some children not to be held back
but the science of reading I think is
best practices and I try to incorporate
into this
many components that I saw in
legislation from
other states that have implemented
successful programs Mississippi has
widely been acclaimed for their
initiatives in this area and the results
so so
my question was I guess in the past
we've we've kind of shied away from
designating a specific
program
um and use the term best practices and
so
is is the science of reading a
program that's put out by a corporation
or is it uh is is it a set curriculum
kind of thing or is it I mean it sounds
good science of reading but
um I know from teaching when we got
locked into a certain type of reading
that uh program for kids all of a sudden
a bunch of kids couldn't read and same
thing with math when we got locked into
one math program that was nationally
ranked you know another one so
um best practices is what we've normally
gone to right thank you
um
yes I the science of reading is not a
product from any particular publisher
it's it's really a concept based on the
research that has been gathered and the
um uh primary components which are
listed on the page top of
um
I thought it was page two maybe it's top
of Page Three
um
that make up the science of reading and
so
um yeah go ahead sorry yes follow-up
um just a another completely different
question but when I saw your bill and
also from working with Katie on the
other one
um I'm wondering why we wait till third
grade to give the the school's money
rather than wouldn't it be great if when
the student is identified and
interventions are necessary that at that
time that the school could apply even if
it had to be just on a yearly basis but
they could apply for the funds at that
time to help the student out rather than
waiting to third grade and saying oh you
know we didn't help 50 kids so we need
this amount of Grant um so we're keying
the money
to the specific
um problem rather than waiting till
third grade and collecting the
non-readers together
in the reading Improvement Grant you're
speaking of
um I I think it does say third grade
students
um but um I would be open to discussing
um you know something earlier than that
as well
I do have a question uh representative
cordelli uh thank you for all the
information you've provided obviously
you've done a lot of work and background
and it's much appreciated
uh the query that I have or maybe two uh
this committee has been reluctant
in the past
to pass legislation that dictates a
specific form of instruction
my presumption here is that if this if
uh 437 were in a pass
this would then provide the reading
component
for the state is that correct is that
how you view this
um I I think for some districts that are
using older techniques it might be a
shift in their reading instruction but I
think that based on all the research and
what we've seen happen in in literacy
around the country I think it's a shift
that needs to take place
and thank you um if I could just add one
follow-up to that
um
as you'll see in some of the exhibits it
really is a follow-on to something that
the department has already started with
their literacy programs and training of
of teachers and students excuse me
students uh teachers and parents okay
the second of my three questions is that
how has this then deal with local
decisions that the local school
districts would make as as they look at
their student population
Etc and determine what programs they
feel would be best How would how does
this meet with that local control
component
um I I think there there would be
flexibility for local districts in in
um the exact instruction and curriculum
related to the science of instruction
um but um there are people here from the
Department
um who might be able to uh discuss that
further as well
okay so I I just got the nod from the
department so I think once we once we
get through with your questions we'll
have the experts come through and who
ask them a series of questions too are
there further questions yes uh
representative Woodcock and then
representative Hall followed that thank
you thank you chairman uh I was like
there's no question that that literacy
instruction is is critical this is the
foundational piece forever I I concur
with you on that thank you for bringing
this forward
um a couple of specific questions
however uh on the part in in Glenn in
section one are you talking about the uh
K3 instruction uh line is seven and
eight I'm assuming that's that's
annually it didn't say annually but you
have on the line is that does that mean
annually so the students we will be from
from a student uh analyze or screened in
grade K or one then are also screening
grade two and grade three but that's
just one shot
uh yes in in all of those um grades in
uh uh line nine
um through uh through ten
um I I with the word repeated in there
at mid-year at the end of the school
year
um I've tried to indicate through those
grades well yeah I I understand that but
that's a year so my question is would a
student be screened annually grades K
grade one grade two grade three or just
yes and um as a matter of fact
um in subsequent years mid-year and the
end of the school year past kindergarten
um they would be screened uh twice in
those years okay if I may if I follow up
yes sir
um I appreciate the fact you put in
about the dyslexia we had that piece
before they were talking about annually
through grade three and that would that
um yes and I'll get copies of the
humanity okay and the final if I may yes
thank you
um
they're online
um section two now on the on your
highlight in the Highlight is very
interesting I mean really well done
thank you on a section two of your
highlighted piece uh on the talking
about line 18 and 19.
my concern is uh not the notification uh
my concern is reading the notifications
multiple times within this document I'm
just trying to figure out
when an elementary teacher is going to
be able to do all this
um where you're talking four weeks every
four weeks it's like multiple classrooms
I'm thinking of low performing schools
where there are multiple youngsters uh
I'm just trying to figure out their
their at some point we take away uh
instructional time to create paper time
and that concerns me particularly in
schools that are under supported in
terms of administrative assistance and
those types of things are preparers
whatever I'm just concerned that we're
we're
not negating the need for Parental
notification money is what I'm talking
about is the frequency throughout your
bill which which is which is multiple
um I just don't know who is going to be
able to do it when when they're trying
to teach during that short window during
the day for our students
um thanks for the question I I I I think
it could be a simple email to the
parents
um during that time frame but
um this was something that
um I found in um multiple States
successful States and also
um had reviewed by uh some national
experts um in um reading and literacy
who revealed this bill for me also but
um if the committee would like to change
the frequency
um it's the committee's bill now last
one one final one thank you thank you
it's not the frequency Glenn okay I
don't know if you're going to do it I
don't know who's going to do it I mean
some of these other schools you may be
cool you may have A's in the class and
do it I just don't know how a teacher in
today's classroom particularly in a low
performing school with 30 kids in a
class is going to be able to keep up
with this on a regular basis and do all
this I just think we're losing and I
don't know what the the give and take is
because we're losing instructional time
time to do paper time to notify the
parents that's all I thought that's the
problem that I see I the concept was
fine I just that makes that's my concern
I'm not sure this maybe someone you've
talked to in some of the other states
may have that answer how they do it
would be helpful thank you thank you Mr
chairman uh representative Hall
thank you Mr Sharon thank you for taking
the question
um on lines 30 and 31 uh you identify
which page representations which page oh
page
well paid one okay sorry page one uh
what they can't do and that is the to
employ the three queuing System model of
reading do you have a sense of how many
schools districts how many school
districts do that now
um I I do not uh perhaps someone in the
department
um might have a better uh idea of that
okay thank you okay other questions uh
represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair
um I've just rapidly done as much
research as I can in a short period of
time on this program science of reading
I'm looking at their ebook
in which uh they have an equity
statement that promotes the teaching
advocacy of social justice and the
teaching of a new social contract to
students so I'm wondering how much do we
know about this program and their and
their efforts to push social
programs on students uh I'm not sure
um uh who publishes that ebook I have
not read it but I have not read anything
like that in in other documents or nor
in the document that I included in the
hand app thank you thank you
representative Ford
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question is there data on this
program as how it works with students
whose families are not speaking English
speakers is there any evidence or
whatever on that
um I I do not um but I can check with
some of the national people that I've
I've worked with to see if they are
aware of any information in that regard
uh representative cascadden
representative Leno
thank you representative Myler as chair
and thank you representative cordelli
for the information it's very valid and
literacy is definitely what kind of
society are we going to have if we don't
have a literate population that is so
valid
um but you're in my area of expertise so
I'm hoping I can help
from 1986 to 2009 I was the principal of
two k-3 schools at the same time
and I have to differ on science
evidence-based reading just coming to
the Forefront because in the 1990s there
were seven schools and you may be
familiar with national reading first
which we participated in which involved
a lot of training all based on the new
sciences and evidence base of the five
components of reading which today are
still those same five components of
phonics phonemic awareness fluency
comprehension and vocabulary
um and I just want to address a little
bit
um
why is state legislators are we trying
to act like teachers because I feel it's
in my role previously yes this was my
job I needed to make sure that the
teachers from K to 3 assessed every
student three times a year and those
that struggled with academics or reading
skills were progress monitored and
parents were at the table every
trimester or every quarter whatever the
school had decided so I know that
communication is pretty tight at those
levels it would seem um
I don't know I find it the teachers who
are teaching reading and cater 3 are
Pre-K to three are bachelor degree in
master's degree trained people
why why would you why should legislation
get in that room and act as a teacher I
I just don't understand the connection
um I I don't I don't I'm I'm certainly
not trying to act as a teacher
um
I was a Sunday school teacher but that's
about it
um
[Music]
it really gets into
um why you know maybe in some areas they
have
um progressed as you've indicated but in
many areas they have not they're still
um using instructional methods and uh
books from certain Publishers who are
um using these older techniques
um and one of the main Publishers who
um are still providing an information
and textbooks based on some of the
authors that you heard about under 377
Lucy Hawkins
Etc
the major publisher of their works is
um
and
to a large degree with
so many things money comes into play and
these instructional methods and
textbooks are still being pushed around
the country and to Publishers it's a
large
source of Revenue I'm not saying that
money is their only motive but Lucy
Hawkins has moved on from what she
originally said
to embrace some of these New
Paths
but I'm not trying to act as a teacher
I'm just trying to make sure that New
Hampshire
throughout the state is moving in the
right direction with literacy
follow up please thank you and I
certainly appreciate that I understand
the need for sure so thank you
um
my question goes
um it's a little twofold with the
reporting
um that it that is stated would that
include reporting for all students in
public and private schools and home
school students to make sure that we are
catching all students with literacy
skills
and with the Department of Ed fund this
program because I suspect if there are
schools still using Lucy Calkins and
faunas and Pennell that local funding is
the difference between whether they can
buy an updated textbook or not
do you know there are two there are two
parts to that question right
one is the reporting who who has to
report the other is the funding of it uh
representative Cordell right thank you
um yes this is um for um Public Schools
um it does not apply uh to uh to private
or homeschooling
um and um in terms of
textbooks and instructional materials I
think that they're if they're still
using some of
um the uh older versions
um from Hawkins and the others
um that there will be a gradual shift
there is no dollars in um
um in this bill appropriated for new
instructional materials I I don't see
that we often provide funding for
another problem
yep
um
so with local control I don't understand
why we're promoting a certain program
because schools have used nwea they've
used star they've used the new Dibbles
acadians those are all effective
measures of reading
um
I lost my train of thought I'm sorry
um I'm passionate about it as you can
tell
yeah I don't think it's our job to be
doing commercials but
um commercial programming to vendors but
I I think I wanted to touch on the
funding
and you know I come from a community
that you don't replace textbooks very
often but hopefully the teachers will
develop materials that will be current
um in the field which often happens in a
poorer District so right
um I don't know if I had that right in
terms of funding I do specify
in the first page there that if there is
any costs
to the screeners that would be
implemented to the local districts that
those costs would be picked up by the
department
and the department would be charged with
coming up with an approved list of
screeners
um I've looked at approved lists from
other states
and there are a number including dipples
of uh
valid screeners out there evidently that
the department would be
charged with identifying and then
providing if there was any cost involved
representative luno
thank you very much Mr chair
I think um representative Cassie Adams
um boa covered um my concern or my
question uh president could you turn on
your mic we can't hear you sorry about
that yeah thank you thank you very much
uh representative Woodcock and uh and
and
I think representative cascadden's um
question
um covered uh what I was what I was sort
of get what I wanted to get at
um but
um but with respect to Universal reading
screeners
um uh what sort of um
standards I guess are other states using
to you know when developing um An
turn on my mic I I don't recall any uh
criteria that's set out but I can
certainly identify uh screeners that
have been approved by other states
um but I'm not sure the criteria and I
probably leave that to the department to
determine
thank you
uh
correctly if I the current the current
charge the current the grant that's
given is for Readiness how much is that
now is it it's a 740 per student and is
about 2200 uh students
um as of 2022 so I think that the
reading Improvement Grant since it
covers
um pretty much all students rather than
just a subset of the population as the
current differentiated Aid will produce
a substantially higher
[Music]
money going to the districts
representative Tanner
thank you and I just wanted to follow up
on uh one of um Representatives
cascadden's remarks was that in the
first part of the of the bill it says
all public schools and Charter Public
Schools uh but then when it gets to the
reporting section I noticed that that it
singles out each local school district
or each School District board
um and it seems like uh and I I guess
piggy backed on that is do Charter
Schools also receive the the grade 3
reading funding and if if they do
shouldn't they have to do the reporting
as well
thank you for the question and that
probably was an Omission on my part in
terms of specifying local school boards
and so forth um but you know we can
expand that to make sure that charter
schools are covered in that
oh do Charter Schools do receive that
the grade three
grant for reading
they currently do receive the
differentiated Aid yes
do any of the uh private schools receive
that or no no okay uh just a follow-up
uh representative cordelli you'd
indicated that it was a thousand dollars
for students who would receive this but
isn't there something in the bill here
that refers to just to a thousand
um yes that's that's correct
um and um I would certainly be open to
expanding
um the grade levels for which that Grant
was uh uh provided so your intent would
be to provide it for any student that
who's under this program to receive that
Grant not just third graders I I would
uh not have a problem with expanding
that correct thank you further questions
from the committee uh representative
Damon
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
so you indicated that we don't know the
number of schools that are doing the
three queuing approach in New Hampshire
I'm referring to
do we know the number of schools who are
already doing the science of reading
uh yes and that that question might be
able to be answered too by the
department of Representatives who I'm
sure we're going to bring up and have
other have an in exchange with them
representative cascad thank you it'd be
a short one
um thank you so we know that brain
development is at its most rapid Pace
from birth to age five
and I guess you you've worked
extensively on this k-3
um which is very valid of course
but I I'm wondering do you know if
there's any such work being done for a
universal preschool or children at age
three and four with a pre-reading skills
really
would start I would think that would be
the precursor to some of this do you do
you know
um I'm not aware of any but there might
be some going on and actually that just
triggered thought and I would have
actually liked I would like to see
whether it's this bill or in the budget
um actually an appropriation to New
Hampshire Public Libraries
to expand summer reading programs yeah
I've talked to the children's librarian
further further questions
uh thank you representative cordelli for
bringing this before this committee now
we have representatives from the
Department
uh could you come up and see if he might
be able to provide some resources for us
as we look at this bill
good morning Melissa white division
director for learner support at the
Department of Education
athlete McCaffrey the ELA consultant for
so I have let me start with a question
uh obviously this is a pretty uh very
comprehensive proposal that before us in
uh 437. could you give us just an
overview of the current status of
reading programs within the state and
also specifically what the department is
doing now to provide resources to school
districts on reading
so um I I think one thing to clarify is
that the local control will still exist
with when we're talking about reading
instructions so tier one reading
instruction instruction that is for all
students is decided at local control and
that will remain there this proposed
legislation is specifically targeting
the students that are needing an
intervention the students that are
exhibiting or reading deficiency so when
we talk about a reading program those
schools can continue to utilize their
existing programs it doesn't necessarily
have to be science of reading based that
they're providing at tier one they can
decide that locally but when we're
looking at the students that are
exhibiting the the most need for an
intervention for reading then where this
proposed legislation is stating that
should be based in the science of
reading but they can continue to decide
how that tier one or that General level
instruction would work so I I wanted to
just make that differentiation between
it's not all of the students who would
be receiving that necessarily that can
still be decided among the teachers the
parents the community school board and
administration it's the targeted
students that we are focusing on meeting
a specific intervention that should be
based on the science of reading so I
wanted to make that clear currently
um there is a mix
across the state we have many schools
that are using
tier one materials or their tier one
instruction is based in the science of
reading other schools may not be and so
it really does vary the Department of
Education really
um
and I think for me personally to one of
the the impetus of going to work for the
Department was because of reading and
reading instruction across the state and
this passion to increase that
those resources and that knowledge and
that training and so
fortunately with covert relief funds we
were able to have the funding to start
to implement a lot of that programming
and that's where I lean into literacy
initiative came in where we were able to
look at science of reading providing
instruction
and professional development
opportunities Statewide to all teachers
and also for Early Childhood Educators
as well parents and any Librarians
anyone that was interested are working
with students that wanted to be a part
of that training so we don't require it
but we do make it available
for
um Educators that do complete the entire
program it's a rather extensive program
taking about two years
they are then able to earn a stipend
they'll have a micro credential that
demonstrates that they have completed
this training so that we have tried to
create as many incentives as possible to
Garner interest to Garner participation
for this programming but again we're not
requiring it and they may participate as
needed in addition we are also training
administrators so that they have a
special training that's just for
administrators in our communities to
really focus on what is science of
reading look like in in the classroom
tier one and then what would it also
look like for interventions how can you
be going into the classroom and making
sure
school-wide that students that are
demonstrating a specific need for
reading intervention are receiving those
services
a question could you Define Tier what
tier one is sure tier one is instruction
for everybody okay tier two is then when
you start to kind of go up the tiers
um levels of intervention needed to
um
kind of make up that deficiency that
we're seeing okay but thank you very
much or any other questions yes uh
representative Cornell thank you so
classroom teachers would be able to use
whatever the district used for reading
until it was discovered that a student
needed more and then that same classroom
teacher would have to know
science of reading and be using the
regular District readings program and
then the other one for their other
students so that's a locally decided
decision if the administration locally
decided they wanted the classroom
teacher to give that intervention in the
classroom then that would be for them to
determine if they wanted their reading
interventionists or their reading
specialist teacher to provide that
intervention then they would have that
person do it so it's really up to local
control who provides the intervention
all this I think and this is my
understanding is that this legislation
is just proposing that the students be
screened and then if they're identified
a plan be implemented to meet that that
need and the instruction being provided
or the intervention be based in the
science of reading so they could use any
intervention that was based in that
there's multiple products out there it's
not just science of reading as one
program or one product you go buy out
the Shelf there's the ability for a
teacher to develop their own materials
based on science of reading it's not a
representative Tanner
thank you
um do you see a benefit
of changing the funding for the reading
interventions from
a grant in third grade to actually tying
it to the specific child and the when
it's when the child is diagnosed and
then the intervention so if if a school
had
five students that were identified in
first grade they could then reap that
money at that first grade level to
provide uh training and intervention
I think it's important to determine how
we are going to like base currently on
the current legislation the way that
it's set up is that it's at third grade
and it's based on Statewide assessment
scores so it's one test all students
take it's it's
um
it's easy to compare the results because
they're all taking the same test as
opposed to
under third grade if you're looking at K
to two there's multiple tests being
offered at the local level multiple
tests are not necessarily comparable so
it could be
um important to clarify how we're going
to ascertain what that deficiency is K
to and what tools will we be using will
it be based on the screener will it be
based on another assessment so I think
that's just the part that would need to
be clarified
um
for us to be able to then determine how
to move forward to calculate whether it
would be K to two because right now
we're set up to assess third grade we
get that results we can go in and look
at that data at the department schools
look at it as well parents can see it so
that's something that's a little bit
more level because we're all using the
same tool
uh follow up please follow up um
so
our Charter Schools our Charter Schools
required to administer that third grade
test and and I noticed that in the
statistics like uh the Academy of Arts
and Sciences doesn't have any reporting
on their reading proficiency
um so at the higher levels
um
I I'm just worried that we're missing
kids and that we're not adequately
funding in that we're
we're really putting a lot of pressure
on local schools to come up with money
and time
that that really needs to be looked at
in the grand scheme of things thank you
for that question so all students in
public and public chartered schools are
required to take reading and Ela
assessments third through eighth grade
and then we take it again an 11th grade
utilizing the SAT
science is assessed at 5th and 8th and
11th grade
and it's utilizing the New Hampshire SAS
assessment our New Hampshire Statewide
assessment system so all of those
schools including the Academy of Arts
and Design are required to take that
assessment
uh okay since uh yes uh representative
Cornell Thank you thank you for taking
another question do all schools have a
reading special specialist on staff does
every school have one that I don't know
the answer to that I know that there are
requirements that are specific to
certifying to be a reading specialist
but I'm not sure if all schools have a
reading specialist
thank you
um I have one last question
currently
when a child is uh
being not proficient and is uh receives
a grant the school district receives a
grant
there's been some questions under the
current system
of how school districts use that Grant
and if in fact they even use the grant
for what it was intended to
it seems to me that under uh 437
that is more targeted with greater
reporting
on how those funds are being used would
you agree with that with my assessment
of that
so my understanding is that it's
currently tacked on to the correct uh
the student aid right so I would think
that it's all accounted for as one
amount of like one chunk of money right
for lack of a better term
um so that's my understanding if this is
setting it up to be a like a specific
Grant that's not tied to student aid
then I think we would just have to
clarify what all of the uh requirements
would be for us to
um
account for that that piece of it if
it's being distributed as a grant
versus student aid those are two
separate instructions we get that
clarified I think when we are an exec
session so thank you other further
questions of the department
not appearing thank you for the
clarification thank you for being here
and thank you for the work you do in
helping school districts
okay uh are there uh
oh yes uh could you also fill out a pink
card so we can have that for uh the
clerk please thank you uh any further
questions on uh 437
uh then we'll declare this closed
foreign
I can
introduce it probably gonna do so well I
think
I think one should probably introduce it
foreign
I believe we're ready to move on to uh
House Bill 542 establishing an academic
research and Improvement performance
data analyst in the Department of
Education
oh thank you Mr chair my name is Mel
Miller and I serve Merrimack District 9
the towns of Hopkinton and Beau
um
representative Ladd has just appeared
would you like to come and introduce
introduce you the
bills is the prime sponsor I will defer
thank you very much for the record my
name is Rick Ladd I'm representative
from from Haverhill Grafton five I also
represent Haverhill land app pyrmont
Warren
Benton I think that's it
and I'm here today to introduce
HB 542 and I'm sure representative Myler
could have done just as great a job as I
am on this one uh seeing we have worked
on this uh during our discussions with
the Department of Education and you as
you may recall we had an orientation
over with uh Nate green who is dealing
with uh various data that we have in I
platform does that ring any bells for
people and then the various components
within and I platform is a wonderful
move going forward and Michael Schultz
has helped do that
and both and that's a contracted service
of doe not a doe staff member Michael
and what we need to do now is that we
need to take this deep dive into what we
have as far as analyzing this data that
we have available to us and making it
available to the public but more
importantly I believe is making it
available in in an understandable manner
to the local school districts and
training school districts District staff
and how to use this in better supporting
our curricular and instructional needs
that we may have in the state a lot of
good things which we are doing in our
our scores compared to the nation are
fine but they are not what New Hampshire
expects New Hampshire always wants to be
at the top of how we're achieving and
with our kids ready going going on for a
career Readiness and with a pathway with
a skill and going into post-secondary
education and not having to spend a lot
of money in remediation
rather than if we're looking at the area
mathematics which we know that that's an
area that's critical and a critical
issue throughout this country
and within New Hampshire and coming out
with a a good ability of how to apply
and use mathematics we've talked about
this the Maya math learning communities
but I after meeting with several groups
now another one since I met with the
folks down at Fairlee and Vermont and
Orford New Hampshire it's an interstate
government District governmental
district for Education that we need to
be working with these teachers and in
administrators in the schools so that
they don't go back and just reinvent
everything in a very at a huge cost
mathematics we may be doing 90 percent
what we need to but there the other 10
percent needs some help and that may be
what's bringing down our achievements
course there's a lot to this
so if we have somebody that's paid at
the department whether the first year I
believe was 160 000 and it drops down
the second year to about 147 000 that's
because the equipment and much of that
has already been purchased the second
year
that person that Doe will help us to
delve down into the nuts and bolts of
where students are in terms of specific
elements within mathematics be it
geometry trigonometry calculus general
math algebra one two and so this person
is needed the department sees this as a
as a primary goal to try and provide the
support for uh Nick green over there to
deal with and analyze this data
so you got to understand too at the
figures I'm going to guess a little bit
here that of those employed over at the
Department of Education close to 80
percent of those are paid through
Federal monies and what we're doing on
the our side is appropriating dollars
for doe to operate it's very thin and
skinny and this is where we can help out
where we need to put the the our
priority issues and I believe that I I
agree of course with the Department this
data analysis individual is is really
needed we've been sitting on top of a
lot of information how many times I
called over doe trying to get
information from them about students our
performance and curriculum or
instruction and I just don't get the
answer they don't have it we don't
compile that we don't do that I've tried
to even in when we had the commission
that represented Miler chaired on the
commission for for funding adequacy we
were asking some questions in terms of
Career Technical education or in terms
of
areas that of curriculum and we did not
get all the information we needed yes we
were able to get National figures but
sometimes the data was just not
available so we had to rely upon those
areas and determining what the average
cost of an adequate education was of
what data the the department had
it may have been out in the school
districts but it wasn't available on the
on the department level so in closing
we're we're really needing this position
uh I think at the primary end of this
thing is that we're going to be helping
education and helping our students
better succeed with this help of an
additional analyst over at the
Department of Education
I'll be God take any questions if you
haven't uh thank you representative any
questions for the uh chairman uh
representative Belcher thank you Mr
chair
um I just wanted to see some
clarification on the on the role of this
position is this
is this purely supposed to be a data
um numbers position or is there an
advocacy and enforcement role in this
this person is a person's going to be
working directly with Nate Green in that
department analyzing this data and also
available and gives more time for either
Nate or the individual hired to work
with school districts perhaps even get
to these School Districts The whole idea
behind that is not to have another
Hammer that the idea is to provide the
information to the district so they will
be able to make those choices and those
decisions on a local level I don't think
there's any District that I visited that
doesn't want their students to achieve
however they put the district's time
this District I'm in right now we have a
superintendent of schools we have so
many in charge special ed we have
somebody in charge of the basic areas of
others areas such as curriculum we don't
have the ability to do what this deep
dive that this person will be doing we
have many small districts out there just
don't have the expertise available and
this will help out
thank you
further questions
uh representative cascadden
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative Vlad I couldn't agree
with you more in my 41 years I can't say
a time that I have not ever had support
guidance advice from anyone who has
worked at the department of Ed so kudos
to them they have a toughs job and I
know you know with so many schools in
the state trying to compile all of this
information is is pretty critical
because it gives us a Guiding Light on
how to move forward
um but I ask if this person is going to
collect Improvement performance data
would he or she
be reaching out only to Public Schools
or or are we looking at performance of
all children in the state
that's a good question
um I wrote this bill initially to hire
an analyst to be working with the the
green to analyze the Statewide
assessment and to analyze other areas of
financial data that we have to try and
determine where our needs are and where
our strengths are in in achievement and
in how we support whether it's involved
with uh it should be involved with
Charters Public Schools I don't Envision
this person being involved with private
schools at all all right just curious
yeah thank you
representative Cornell Thank you
thank you for taking my question on
lines eight nine I said the the position
shall be subject to any other employment
requirements as determined by the
department does that mean the department
can say oh we we need more help over
here so we're just going to pull you for
a time and usually put something else
that's part of the job description that
they put together over there and if I
were hiring a teacher I'd put the same
thing in the bottom line
um
yeah I think representative cascadden
understands what I'm saying but this is
as just standard operating sop for them
over there you look at Amy Clark's job
right now we know she's a building aid
person but other things she does the the
laundry list is long and that's because
we
we know those of us been on this
community for years know that we just
have not staffed doe the way we need to
staff when I first got here we had
curriculum Frameworks which were
guidelines and they had been updated as
recently as 2007 2008 when I came on
board we haven't done that since and so
we had a curriculum staff which was able
to help the school districts in
identifying what the curriculum might
look like and then we get there were
guidelines that doesn't exist because we
don't staff those positions
representative also knows exactly what
I'm talking about when he worked over
there there was a larger staff when
we're dealing with uh
15 years ago but now it's changed so
they're they're just kind of reacting
and we need to get them out of that
reacting mode into the acting and and
uh representative try
thank you Mr Vice chairman
um who is this person accountable to at
the Department of Education this person
would be working directly with the
person that it would be in the
curriculum side and that's Caitlyn but
Nate Davis that whole Department's
downstairs in the building we were in on
the basement level and that's where
building Aid is that's where queer Tech
is that's where uh all the areas which
we're dealing with curriculum and so
that analyst is also down there so it'd
be directly uh directly reporting to
Caitlyn Davis as the Director
thank you
further questions uh see none thank you
uh do we have any other pink cards for
this
no no is there anyone else who wishes to
testify
I've seen none
um
I'll close the hearing on uh House Bill
542 and it looks like we have a break
for lunch until 12 45 and our next bill
now you know
can you ask your people where we are on
that though so that we might be able to
I might I might add to the committee and
for the public that's present this bill
which we just did may be acted upon
today in terms of executive session
so just putting that notice out as we
foreign
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
education committee for the opportunity
to present House Bill 334 FN I am
representative Tom Schamberg of
Merrimack County six I represent the
towns of Wilmette and Sutton
and I'm serving my fourth term on the
house ways and meetings committee as the
chairman has read House Bill 334 is an
act relative to the determination and
cost of State adequate education and
this bill would change the calculation
for the per pupil amount for grants for
the opportunity for an adequate
education to be one half of the
Statewide cost per pupil in consultation
and discussion with the residents of
Wilmette and Sutton while knocking on
doors like a lot of you did in this last
election cycle it was strongly suggested
that the financial
sacrifices that were being made by the
residents of Wilmette and Sutton to fund
the public education of the Cure Sarge
Regional School District was straining
their wallets paying property taxes for
public education while the amount of aid
from the state of New Hampshire through
its legislature was skimpy
question is why
from Jamie Vollmer
who stated that once upon a time the
Mandate from society was simple let's
teach our children not so anymore as a
society we have changed what we ask our
schools to do and how much these changes
have cost
from the vulner list
here are 127
responsibilities
that have been dumped on
our schools since 1900.
the chart shows that social
and economic conditions are compelling
the public schools of New Hampshire to
prepare the full potential of every
child in our public school system
new responsibility and Duties are being
mandated by Society of New Hampshire
public schools that historically were
performed by families and communities
who is paying the additional mandated
costs
Property Owners of New Hampshire
school funding reported out on December
1st
which some of you served on
it was titled our schools our kids
all public input recognize that their
current funding system dependent on
local property taxes does not provide an
equitable opportunity for an adequate
education for all students regardless of
where they live
because
and because of the constant skimpy
approach of the legislature not to
respond to the inequities and funding
litigation has occurred in the past and
now new mitigation on March 13 2019 was
undertaken by Kentucky Valley School
District and three individuals suing the
state claiming that the state has failed
to meet its obligations to fund an
adequate education
as reported in the state of New
Hampshire annual comprehensive report
of June 30th 2021 page 96 under
litigation of Kentucky
Valley School District versus State and
all
though the trial court denied
the plaintiff's motion for the state to
pay the plaintiffs any amount of the 17
million dollars requested instead the
trial court required the legislature to
fix statute RSA 198 colon 40 comma a
dash a comma Roman numeral two on a
prospective basis which means take
action the case was remanded to the
trial court where it remains pending
approximately 12 new school districts
have been added to that action against
the state the question arises of why
such hostility by the state of New
Hampshire government toward funding
public education
Superior Court judge ruoff in 2019 has
stated
the state's present-based adequacy Grant
amount doesn't nearly cover the cost of
Education
in the Concord Monitor form section on
January 12 2020 a group of five New
Hampshire individuals some who are
members
of the New Hampshire school funding
fairness project released
what state adequacy looks like in the
towns of Hopkinton and Pittsfield
the state claimed that Hoppington could
meet the adequate standards with three
million seven hundred and seventy four
thousand two hundred and fifty nine
dollars versus the school budget of 20
million plus
and that Pittsfield could meet adequate
standards with 2 690
330 33 dollars versus a budget of 10
million plus
if these two districts re-budgeted their
school district budgets by eliminating
items to meet the state adequacy Grant
funds they would violate New Hampshire
State minimum standards and federal and
state laws
so the question arises is there a viable
solution that the legislature through
this education committee can use to
comply with its exclusive obligation to
Define and provide funding for an
adequate education
House Bill 334
is that viable solution because it would
provide a policy change in the state
budgetary process of the unrestricted
Revenue to the education trust fund from
the general fund and provide a
long-standing term solution
the present policy of the cost of an
opportunity for an adequate education
using RSA 198 colon 40-a Roman numeral 2
would be replaced by this bill's
language and use the suggested and I say
suggested solution of one half of the
Statewide average cost per pupil to
provide grants for the opportunity
of an adequate education
there are other legislators who sit on
the other side of the aisle from me in
ways and means
who are stressing that they will do
everything they can to rectify the
process that places so much tax burden
on real estate making it difficult to
induce people to move to or build in or
improve in a high tax Town thus tending
to hold valuations down
I have provided copies of this bill to
the Cure Sarge School District
Representatives
the board of selectment of Wilmington
and various members of our present
legislators and the primary question
that arose over and over again was where
will the money come from in the state
budget considering all the other
priorities
can any change be achieved using the
present unrestricted Revenue stream into
the general fund and education trust
fund as stated in 2019 in a newspaper
article by a knowledgeable
representative quote with or without
additional Revenue
it's a house funding formula could be
achieved if there exists a will
the funding problem was created by
humans
humans and if humans created it they can
resolve it
visualize this when working together and
I have a
copies of a passive I'd like to
give to someone that has
oh you're so kind maybe if you split it
visualize this when working together
hey 35
000 pound Barn was moved without
machinery
by humans working together
and the article you can read the bottom
lines there
there were a thousand men there to do it
while that's going around
Jen
pass that
well Jen passes this out
the first chart that she's going to pass
to you
is the chart of ADM and cost per student
based on the Department of Education
the second chart
is the cost in the previous years like
2017 to 18 19 to 20 and then this past
year of
21-22
and it shows each Town what would happen
if we went to one half
of the determination cost for an
adequate education as I said I suggested
thank you
here might as well hold on to this one
has it made it around yet to the Mr
chairman
anymore
[Laughter]
thank you representative Woodcock
Jen would you pass out that half now
put all these in play
this is a chart from the dra
and
what we did is we took
the 2021
and set it at nine thousand dollars per
pupil versus nine thousand two hundred
and it was times 164
000 students at the time
to fund an adequate education at one
half the state costs and the blue sheet
that's coming around presented by the
dra I apologize for the having to strain
your eyes on that one they put the font
at a a very small amount it shows 74
percent of the general fund and Trust
would have to be of the unrestricted
Revenue would have to be
used to meet the nine thousand that's
why I said it's a suggested amount
and that also means
they took off the swept tax off that too
now the sweatpant makes up about 18
percent
percentage so it'll be about 52 percent
would be needed
of the revenue if you don't do away with
the swept tax now there is one caveat to
think about when undertaking this move
to increase the dollar amount of Grants
proposals to reduce Revenue
by a house committee using percentage
rate reduction or elimination or sun
setting of attacks from one of the
present 15 tax groups that filled the
general and education trust fund revenue
is not feasible to achieve an increased
dollar amount per pupil and reduce the
property tax burden from local taxpayers
for citizens of New Hampshire
will not accept excuses of the State
Legislature
who expressed that we don't have the
revenue because it gave
consistent percentage rate cuts
on taxes or elimination of Revenue
sources and neither will the judicial
system accept those types of excuses
a meaningful response is needed now
this education committee can be the
leaders that conceive a solution to this
daunting Problem by creating a system of
funding that removes a lot of the
property tax burden
from our local taxpayers
in a letter dated April 2nd 2019 from
the North Country superintendents to
every state representative serving at
that time and some are still here today
Express this about public education in
New Hampshire
quality public education is the most
important component of a free and
Democratic Society our schools provide
an essential pipeline
for citizenship and Workforce
Development our current path will soon
lead us to economic peril in closing I
ask I am poor this committee
to find the will to respond either
through a subcommittee work or as a
committee of the whole to this inequity
in funding by using this bill House Bill
as a starting point to challenge
legislative spending behaviors and
change the tax burden that threatened to
erode the quality that our residents and
New Hampshire citizens expect from our
schools
thank you Mr chair and I do have uh
copies for the Cork and for you sir and
two extra ones right now thank you very
much are there questions for the
representative represent Belcher let me
just thank you Mr chair I'd just like to
try to clarify uh this this new proposed
formula
um so where it says here uh the cost for
people in the admr shall be one half of
the Statewide average cost per pupil but
then it goes on to define the Statewide
average cost per people meaning the
combined State average of all school
districts average cost per pupil for
total education expenses
isn't that if I'm not mistaken not
actually the average Statewide cost per
pupil but rather the average of the
districts because it's not waiting for
their student populations
what page were you on what line sir
so this is page two lines 13 through 17
this this chart was developed by the
Department of Education they determine
what the cost
average cost
per student would be
throughout the state they take all the
numbers of the adms divided by the uh
amount total amount of all what the
school each district spends and then
they come up with an average cost
if I if I may Mr chair just to clarify
then that yes it is in fact
the average cost of all of the districts
averages and not actually so it's not
all of the students waited then is that
it's the average cost that the district
spends
and they take the total number of
students
they total the entire State that's what
I'm trying to to stress here to get to
okay thank you what are the questions
representative thank you thank you very
much representative Schoenberg for um
for bringing this forward and uh and
also for uh for referencing the work of
the commission I'll be referencing that
uh later on as well but um but uh I I
guess the you know question to you
um and there'll be a follow-up on it as
well but do you do you would you agree
that
um that not every school district and
student population
you know is identical from across the
state
um basically saying that that um that
you know the Manchester school district
and the students that go there aren't
exactly you know just larger population
but the same as the school district and
the students in Pittsfield and the
students and School District in Concord
I would agree all right so so follow up
yeah and a follow-up thank you Mr chair
so what your what you're proposing here
is you know I'll use a somewhat of a
pejorative term a one-size-fits-all
approach to to funding but um but what
would you do then you know if this were
to go through
um what would you do for um for the city
of um of Berlin which currently has per
student state grants a little over 11
000 per student
foreign
that is why I first said I suggested a
percentage amount
I'll leave it up to this committee to
decide
the policy portion of that
but
when I read this
our schools our students our schools our
kids
a Einstein I want to say to interpret
all the things in here
and when you give it to a
resident to read
they go what isn't there a simpler
method
to achieve funding
we do it in our homes
you only have so much money coming in
things that we'll pay for and then we
pay for them it's a it's complicated
[Music]
as I said we've had almost 29 years to
resolve some of these issues
and we just keep adding on layer after
layer after layer of trying to resolve
and balance it all out these school
districts need money now the property
owners need relief now it's a start it
is a start no and again and again thank
you for bringing this forward Mr chair
also I apologize to you and and
representative I have to run to finance
for 115. and I certainly don't mean to
run out on school funding um thank you
thank you well thanks representative
cardelli
uh thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative
um I believe you asked the question
um where will the dollars come from in
the state budget for this and I I wasn't
sure if I heard an answer to the
presently the only way we can uh find
these dollars is our tax system the way
it's set up the money that is collected
and put into the general fund
on obligated monies is where we would
find
the money
for the students but it's going to take
it's going to take a
change in the operating budget and a
change in our priorities a little bit
maybe we don't spend as much on social
programs or we reduce the amount that is
spent on social programs and search for
other aspects from non-profits and and
communities to come up with the money
yes follow-up
so um just so I make sure I understand
the difference of seven hundred thousand
dollars plus
um in this proposal would be taken from
the general fund and a general fund
Appropriations to other programs
Etc would be reduced to make up the
difference in that appropriation is that
correct
yes sir thank you further questions
represent miler
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question I want to follow up
on representative belcher's question
when you start talking about a cost per
pupil
you made reference to the doe 25 form
now the doe 25 form is an annual form
that is filed by each School District
with the department and it covers all
costs of a school district not just
Personnel costs but it covers every
possible cost so you're saying that you
would like to have half of that cost
averaged in the state
that that would be reimbursed from the
state to the local school district is
that correct
without changing the language of this
further questions from the committee
representative cardelli thank you
am I correct in the reading that the
charter school funding would be changed
so that it would be uh equal to the
appropriation for traditional Public
Schools correct public Charters
yes and one final question I was just
wondering why the removal of
differentiated aid for EFA students
to simplify every school district has
children that meet these qualifications
of five thousand if you it's it's a
differentiated Aid of five thousand
eighty seven dollars
if every school district had that child
it would be applied
someone was going to say well
we don't have third graders
that fall into this so what can we do
with the money
I believe it's up to the school district
thank you I my mother told me Mr
chairman if you don't know the rest of
them answered don't put your foot down
into something else all right
I'm having trouble understanding why
you're using a doe 25 form which reports
our assets our expenditures our revenues
and on the expenditures it minuses out
the transportation which you've
mentioned and tuition which you've
mentioned
the doe 25 form contains all its other
expenditures including those
expenditures
which are
decisions made by the local board that
are not required by adequacy so then why
are you using the doe average of the
from the 25 form when we're not talking
about all the programs necessary for the
delivery of inadequate education
the present time the definition for
adequacy has been established by past uh
legislatures or past committees and
passed by the legislature
this is just a new approach to give the
committee the opportunity to maybe
change the policy
of what adequacy is to maybe change the
definition
it may not include all those items that
you are talking about but it would allow
this committee
can show the residents and the people of
New Hampshire
we can advance some of our definitions a
little bit further than what they've
been established
are you aware as a follow-up question
are you aware that the definition of
adequacy is not in this section of law
the definition of adequacy contained in
193 e and there's no effort here to
address
that change
or a need to change as you're seeing it
people when I drew this up
it was before election time
I understand what you're asking me but I
was going to the central core
of how we get to an adequate funding
and it's money
and
it will always be money and I was hoping
that Mr chairman that maybe
this committee like I said before would
form a subcommittee and say well maybe
we shouldn't go 50 maybe we should look
back some other numbers use a different
percentage 45 40. but make some change
so that the people of New Hampshire the
property owners the business owners who
pay more in property taxes sometimes
than they do on their business profits
tax
give them the idea that something is
being done to address the situation
because the court system is eventually
going to make a decision
someday whether it's in April
and they start hearing this Kentucky
case or
maybe next fall but if they make a
decision and says you will the
legislature of New Hampshire you will do
are we going to have the revenue but the
biggest thing right now Mr chairman
we heard two bills this morning we're
hearing two more in ways and means right
now
everybody wants to cut cut cut cut cut
rates
cut programs cut taxes and
I think it's
thank you are there further questions
from the committee yes representative
Belcher thank you again Mr chairman I
just want to follow up with my own
question from earlier just to really
make sure I have a good concrete
understanding of the proposed formula so
if you bear them with me for a sec if I
throw it a hypothetical if New Hampshire
were to have only two school districts
School District a has a single student
who it costs on average to educate
ninety nine thousand dollars
and in the other District district B has
a thousand students who cost one
thousand dollars on average according to
this formula the average between those
two districts then it's fifty thousand
dollars per student and District B would
be reimbursed at fifty thousand dollars
per student despite the fact that the
cost of education for them is only one
thousand is that
accurate
now that's the only answer I have for
you on that one okay thank you
I think we're looking at the issue of
Moulton Borough we're looking at
Waterville Valley 45 000 per kid we're
looking at Monroe we're looking at some
of those towns which have the ability to
raise those dollars easily and the
others which are not there anywhere near
it so then you're taking the average of
these high and low you might even think
about knocking out some of the high
knocking out some of the low and
figuring out then if you're going to go
that but that's a different area of
mathematics
ghost fan
spend it on has determined at the school
either School District town meeting or
at the deliberative session and then the
vote right and it varies very
differently between schools what some
where you know
uh football field or the you know the
things that aren't
I won't say non-educational because you
learn from everything right I'm just
saying we have great differences
and
I guess I have two
questions one is is it appropriate then
if the state
is giving more money to the school
districts if they then take more control
over what the money is spent for
because we have local control but by
local control some districts will spend
a lot more money I mean two districts
that have the same amount
some will spend a lot more money on
Extras and some will spend a lot more
money on on or a lot less money total
and just I'm just saying so then if
you're paying half
both of those are going in there
that average and so should we then since
we're spending so much more have more
say as to what it's spent for
thus doing away with some of that local
control a question by we do you mean the
legislature
yes well the people who are going to be
yes the gov the government the
legislature the doe whoever because
we're providing more of the money
I feel representative if the legislature
puts down its of stipulations or rules
in the beginning
there shouldn't be a question on what
local control does
going back to your your your example
High versus a Lower Split
once the money is given to the
it allows just say five thousand dollars
it allows the residents the
the people that live in that school
district to make a decision
all right we would like to do this this
this and this
and they then will have more resources
because the state is paying a little bit
more for them to reduce their tax load
and then
local residents can decide okay I'm
going to support the football field I'm
going to support drama
I'm not going to support this this
culinary action but it allows
more money allows the locals to make
decisions of how they will spend the
rest of their tax money
that the school district would like to
spend I think that's where local control
is I think the state should
set the parameters
and
and they should be so restrictive
local control means local control not at
the state house all the time
follow up with that quickly
so then the other the other
part of that is looking at
both historically and across States
um
what often happens if we give the extra
nine thousand dollars next year the
school will have nine thousand more
dollars
increase their taxes saying well we have
this more money coming from the state
until their property taxes are the same
I'm just
wondering what I mean historically
that's what I've seen do you anticipate
that happening well I don't think so
that is my opinion in just my opinion I
don't expect the school district to say
okay we got this extra money let's keep
our tax rate at the same no I think that
uh the residents would say
let's reduce our taxes
let's move it down we
it's tough to answer that it really is
because you don't know what people are
thinking
I just know it's been done right thank
you very much I I got it I'm sure
follow-up question for you have you done
a spreadsheet on this in terms of how
this is going to end this new formula
would uh I haven't looked at that so uh
and the question being
how are we ever going to impact
Implement something like this with the
effective date you have on this bill
I believe that an amendment of this
committee uh or maybe a change in the
percentage could be amended by someone
that is wanting to see an increase but
maybe not as much as I have proposed by
the bill itself
I think that's for this education
committee to decide I I just I put it
out there as a
as something that needs to be addressed
before
we are told what to do as a legislature
thank you for the questions from the
committee
not seeing thank you very much
thank you Mr chairman
yeah yeah I don't think we need it
foreign
welcome
for the record my name is Zach Sheehan
I'm the Project Director of the New
Hampshire school funding and fairness
project
um I did bring written testimony but
have since marked it up and realized
number of uh edits so I'll bring some
printed one after
um for the committee
um for those who don't know the New
Hampshire school funding Affairs project
is a non-profit organization educates
citizens and policy makers about the
system New Hampshire uses to fund its
Public Schools build awareness of those
um I want to hit on a few points where I
brought up uh previously relative to the
bill but first off I'll start by saying
in general we are supportive of the
concept of increasing the amount of
funds that come from the state for
public education a number of the
questions are raised by the committee we
also have some concerns about but in
general we are in favor of increasing
the amount of money
um that the state sends to local
districts
um specifically because of that gap
between the average cost of an adequate
education as defined by the Department
of Education and our current funding
formula
um resulting in only about 4 700 per
student versus the average cost for
people being closer to nineteen thousand
dollars per student and how do we reduce
that Gap to take some of the burden off
of local property taxpayers which is
and so in general uh we see House Bill
334 as being an attempt to close that
Gap
um and for that reason we do support
shifting some of that burden the tune
the cost of taxpayers local taxpayers
for public education is um as reported
by the cushionist high school funding
and other studies over two billion
dollars per year that local property
taxpayers pay for their public education
system and we believe that is the
Constitutional obligation of the state
to fund more if not all of that however
and this was something that was raised
by a number of committee members we do
have concerns about uh wiping out the
current adequacy formula for a kind of
equality approach you know given a flat
rate per students around the state you
know the current Formula about we you
know would have changes to propose to
that and would like to increase the
amount of funding that comes from the
state does take into account different
measures of need not every student needs
the same resources not every school
district needs to same resources and so
we would you know want to keep that with
any changes moving forward so given that
we've already kind of discussed this for
quite a while I'll leave it there happy
to answer any questions committee
members might have thank you very much
are there any questions
not seeing any thank you very much thank
you
now we do have technical support out
there is anything Mark do you want to
offer anything from the Department
or does anybody in the committee have
technical type questions for for Mark
so you survived the previous studies
which we've had on this commercial uh
the commission study Etc even within the
commission study there was an amount set
aside for differentiated Aid in special
education four point now what was it now
4.19 something like that times the the
amount which was established for for per
pupil
um have you done anything are you how
would that how would this approach
impact all those categories of
differentiate English language learner
special education
free and reduced meals reading if
they're remedial not receiving the other
three
Yep this approach for the record
marketing and lo Department of Education
School Finance administrator this
approach does get rid of differential
Aid differential Aid does weight pupils
differently as representative lad was
discussing so it would take out that
weight for special education and that
special education weight would not exist
in the formula take out enough in that
differential Aid F and R weight the
English language learn to wait in the
third grade reading weight but it also
keep components of just uh it would keep
relief Aid as part of the district
formula and extraordinary needs grants
so there would be some weighted
functioning but it wouldn't be as
robust as the current formula as far as
the weights are concerned um it would
just be a flat that nine thousand uh
number and I have one last follow-up
question how would this approach and the
figures which you see right here impact
catastrophic you know special education
Aid
three and a half times up to
80 100 percent uh a completely
um making holding everything constant
um this would have no impact the only
time the only way it would impact on
sped Aid is if districts received
additional funding and then they
increased their expenditures
um so if they received additional Aid
the 700 plus million dollars and then
they use that all to basically supplant
local tax dollars then that would have
no impact on the cost per pupil
generally speaking
um but if they increase their
Appropriations and increase their
expenditures then it would increase the
cost per pupil which include impacts the
sped Aid formula because the sped Aid
formula triggers at 3.5 times the cost
per pupil so and that's way it would
impact the sped Aid formula
under those assumptions I guess I have
one last one for you as you said all
that the money that we have for base
adequacy and differentiated is not
targeted money
at this point time in other words this
doesn't doesn't go to necessarily
especially it might go for fixing a roof
so yeah and taking this tax right here
is all the funding within what we're
seeing coming from the state where this
you know one half the cost of the doe 25
form is that all non-targeted money now
so uh um good question I think there's a
a difference in maybe jargon and when we
use the word targeted versus when we use
um how the money's used so targeted
typically when I use the word targeted
I'm talking about
is the a targeted for a particular
demographic but but you're getting to
the next question is okay it's targeted
for that demographic is it required to
be spent on that demographic so our
differential Aid components are targeted
in a sense that we uh count a sped
student as reserving uh uh uh the school
needs more aid for each sped student
they have so it is targeted in that
regard but adequacy as it currently is
inadequacy under this legislation is
always unrestricted so adequacy is never
mandated to be spent on a particular
program it is always
um the discretion of the local uh
community that that answers it
representative cardelli and thank you Mr
chairman uh thank you for being here
um we've had some discussion about the
Statewide average cost per pupil and the
doe 25. could you touch on the
components of the doe 25 and maybe
specifically also what is included in
terms of special education costs on the
doe 25 whether it's state and or local
so the doe 25
it's meant to show
a full Financial yearly Financial
picture of a district it does it's not a
full um it's not as robust as a full
audit it does not try to tally up all of
their long-term assets but it's supposed
to be a snapshot of their revenue
expenditures for a full year and it's
supposed to it is intended to capture
all expenditures all revenue received
there is some parsing out in some some
account coding that gets us a little bit
granular but is an um
it does not it struggles to get to the
granularity that some people would like
for special education uh we do have it's
called supplemental reporting we do have
some supplemental reporting where
districts are required to parse out
their specific special education costs
on the doe 25 so we do
capture that data
um the doe 25 is is not an audited
um uh typically not an audited document
it is reviewed by the department is
submitted by the districts it is used in
in in financial reporting in his Houston
tax rate setting
um
we do have special education data I
think last time I spoke last time I
looked at it and last time I spoke to
this committee about that question
because it comes up a lot I think we
spend about 750 million dollars
Statewide on special education each year
each year
um and District Public Schools according
to the doe 25. yo follow-up yes thank
you
um in terms of the expenditures that are
shown on the doe 25
that would Encompass things Beyond
academic instructional
expenditures things such as
administrative costs
um athletic costs
um activity costs
um is that correct
that is correct it includes um all of
those items you discussed it includes
their full Financial spend anything that
district is spending money on it is
required to be poured on the reported on
the doe 25. thank you thank you are
there any other questions for the
Department
uh we have no more pink cards on this
particular bill so with that I'm going
to close the hearing
and the next hearing schedule to start
foreign
HP 334 will be that bill
no excuse me 4 30. I've got to jump down
yes
foreign
thank you we're ready now to go ahead
with the next hearing uh which would be
HB 430 FN local relative to applications
for Education Freedom account programs
and representative luno you're the prime
sponsor welcome terrific thank you very
much Mr chair members of the uh of the
education committee my name is Dave luno
I represent the people of Merrimack
County District 9 which are the towns of
Bowen Hopkinton
um when the EFA program was introduced
back in the fall of 2021 the
commissioner of education and others
presented the EFA program as an
opportunity for students who are not
succeeding in their Public Schools
and to make a change
to provide an alternative to their local
public school
of course we all know that that's not
true other alternatives are readily
available to all students and families
such as charter schools and attendance
at Public Schools outside of the
resident's own District through the
state's relatively new manifest
education hardship law that we worked in
this committee on so hard together in
2019 collaboratively both Republicans
Democrats and the stakeholders too
but still the commissioner of education
did make a case for Education Freedom
accounts based on helping students who
did not have the resources to leave
their public school and choose an
alternative for their education needs
and a big point to make here to do it in
a way that results in substantial
savings for the local property taxpayer
since they wouldn't no longer be on the
hook to pay the local costs to educate
that student who leaves their Public
School
there's plenty of examples from
interviews news releases and media
coverage and even the Department's own
website and this from the website
quote this program has grown
significantly
just a little feedback sorry this
program has grown significantly in that
faster Pace than other states that have
adopted similar initiatives while it has
exceeded our expectation it is exciting
and encouraging to know that New
Hampshire families now have the
opportunity to determine the best
educational Pathways for their children
and that economically disadvantaged
students will also have various options
to fit their personal learning needs and
that's quoted directly from a
commissioner of Education Frank
edelbrook edelblue
a recent uh Department news release also
States quote education Freedom accounts
allow eligible New Hampshire students to
direct state-funded per-pupil education
adequacy grants towards select
educational programming of their choice
for a variety of learning experiences
there are currently 3025 students
enrolled in the EFA program that is
offering grants totally nearly 14.7
million dollars this school year that's
all part of the commissioner's quote
um the cost to taxpayers would be about
65 million dollars if the 3025 students
who are all eligible attended a
traditional public school that's all in
the the Department's news release
in a December 2020 interview with the
Josiah Bartlett Center Governor Chris
sununu went on to say quote it's going
to have huge impacts on property taxes
huge impacts on on just the individual
tax base of the state not quite sure
what he meant by the last part but I'll
I'll take him at his word that that he
expected the uh the education Freedom
count to have huge impacts on to reduce
property taxes
but according to the Department of
Education about 400 of the newest 1453
EFA students and this is also in a quote
from from Department news relief only
only 400 of the newest 1453 fa students
for this year switched from a public
school to an education Freedom account
program about 27 percent
and according to the department EFA fact
sheet from November 2021 there were only
280 students out of the 1635 who left
their public school and took a voucher
for the first year of the program only
280 of those students actually left
their Public School
so if we add this up
today only about 680 of the
approximately 3 200 EFA students
attended a public school during the year
prior to joining the program the other
students were not attending public
school maybe there were private schools
or maybe they were at home schools but
in any event they weren't costing
taxpayers 65 million dollars in fact
they were costing taxpayers nothing
say that again
based on the Department's own numbers
nearly 80 percent of the EFA students
were already were not in public schools
and not costing taxpayers a dime
but since the program was enacted as
part of the 2020-23 state budget the EFA
program has cost taxpayers more than 23
million dollars and the commissioner of
education has requested an additional 60
million dollars for the next two years
of this program
so House Bill 430 clears this up saves
taxpayers millions of dollars and make
sure the EFA program doesn't turn into a
taxpayer-funded private school tuition
program
the bill simply requires students to be
enrolled in their public school when
they apply for an EFA exception is made
for students who are entering
kindergarten or first grade it's
straight out of the amendment out of an
amendment to Senate Bill 193 from 2018.
it's actually for the record amendment
number 2530h that was sponsored by reps
lad and cordelli
the Bill's fiscal note says quote this
bill will result in an indeterminable
number of students falling out of the
program
I don't know what they mean by that or
where that comes from this is nonsense
and it's blatantly incorrect
Hospital 430 has no impact on students
already in the EFA program it simply
we're committed to improving the
accountability oversight and
transparency of the EFA program would
the commissioner now asking for 60
million dollars of taxpayer money in the
next budget for it
it's more important than ever that
taxpayers know how their money is being
spent and the results thank you Mr chair
members of the committee and be happy to
take some questions thank you very much
representative Luna are there questions
for the representative
yes represent like this
thank you thank you for taking my
question
um I've seen things like this put into
place in other states and what they
experienced was a whole lot of people
suddenly registering for public school
for one year and I'm wondering do you
so
um thank you very much for the question
I'm not sure I understand the scenario
if they're already in the EFA program
they don't have to go back to public
school for a year to remain it to
reapply back into the the EFA program
for
um for um for other students they would
you're right have to be in public
schools which is the entire premise that
one of the key premises that that the
program was uh was founded on by the
commissioner of education and um and uh
uh except if they're going into
kindergarten or first grade they could
apply directly without having to attend
a public school but if they're in third
second grade or or later all they need
to do is apply and um and uh go through
the application process with the
children's scholarship fund
representative Belcher yeah your hand up
thank you Mr chair
um oh I certainly share the the
understanding that we have at all times
must balance the taxation versus our
need to educate
um children
um but can you speak to the
um the ethics surrounding the Supreme
Court case on adequacy funding as it
would relate to
seemingly arbitrarily prohibiting
certain students from accessing efas if
they don't complete or if they haven't
been in school for a year is is that a
is that a conflict what Supreme Court
court case are you referencing that
required us to come up with the adequacy
funding so so you're talking about the
the state supreme court yes uh in the in
I would say in Con in Clermont and
Claremont 2 in Londonderry yes and so
um it uh Mr chair we could probably have
an entire weekend on this uh this issue
I didn't want to get too deep into
Londonderry so yeah yeah so so uh we'll
I'll um I'll I'll sort of short circuit
of a full you know discussion uh on that
but uh but the state does have a
constitutional obligation to cherish an
education for all of its children I'm
not sure if that's CL I think it's close
to the wording in the Constitution but
um but um uh the state exercises that
responsibility and that constitutional
obligation through a series of public
schools throughout the state I'm sorry
let me make it clear through public
school districts uh throughout the state
and it has a constitutional obligation
to fund an adequate education uh for
those for those public school districts
and I think all of that came out of
Clermont on Claremont 2 and one Dairy um
uh touched on that on that as well
um the state the legislature and by that
I'll say the state has has waded into
other areas over the last decade or more
including charter schools and now the
EFA program neither of which the state
has a constitutional obligation to
provide for its children or to fund
because the existing platform foundation
for public school districts provides
that constitutionally required
obligation
represent Belcher do you have a
follow-up to your question yes please if
that's that's all right
um to switch gears to a different core
for a moment to the Supreme Court who
fairly recently struck down the concept
of the Blaine Amendment saying that if
you're if the state is going to fund any
sort of religious education then they
cannot discriminate
um how does that you think impact the
idea that we're going to arbitrarily say
some students who haven't gone to public
school cannot participate in efas where
other students currently are receiving
that education yeah I I think you're
you're sort of you know mixing metaphors
on on this case
I don't believe the the Supreme Court's
ruling in that is directed to what uh
what this is saying which is uh which is
um you know parameters uh for uh for a
student's family or for a student to
receive money from the state as long as
they meet certain certain criteria none
of it says makes any determination on on
on whether or not they are going to or
would like to go to a religious school
or a um or a non-religious
um school it just basically sets
criteria saying student has to be within
this
grade range eligible to go to a New
Hampshire public school and what this is
adding is uh either be going into the
first or second grade or be I'm sorry
the kindergartner first grade and be a
be a Current public school student
further questions representative
cornelli
uh thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
representative
um so basically with this um legislation
we're interpreting the Constitution to
say that we should cherish uh the
education of a student if they are
attending a public school
is is that correct no that's that's not
what I said what I what I what I said
was the state
um has an obligation to cherish
education for all of its children and it
meets that obligation through a a a a a
a platform of public school districts
which it funds
um um which it funds through adequacy
all across the state
yes
um it's it's not taking away any private
options
um uh for people people can can make
their own educational choices outside of
that but at a minimum it has to provide
um an opportunity for an adequate
education which it does so through uh
through public school districts
so
um
the education of a child who is not
attending a public school
um is not
um covered in the Constitution it's it's
not part of
um a part two article 83 no no of course
that's covered in the Constitution and
that child could receive that that
education through through going to their
Public Schools provided they live in the
um the state of New Hampshire you know
and qualify as as the state you know the
the children who live in the in in the
state of New Hampshire
um and and I'm not aware of very many
adequacy I I I'm not aware that the
state's definition of constitutional
adequacy even provide even applies
outside of the uh the realm of public
schools
one last question yes
um but for any child whose education we
cherish
does not fit into their local public
school
based on their education
needs and their learning styles then
um then they fall out of our
constitutional requirement for that
student no no that's okay that's that's
not true at all the public school
district
um uh is there to provide them with an
opportunity for an adequate education if
that if the student or their family
decides to make a different Choice
that's uh that's completely up to them
and uh and it's also you know completely
up to them to go in and um and you know
make a case in front of their local
school board talk with the teachers make
an appointment with the superintendent
make an appointment with the building
principal or speak to their State Rep
thank you perhaps select us one one
question here and then we gotta move on
we have other people waiting to talk
okay I was um speaking with a rep who
was
here and part of that process at the
time the
um
the ruling came down 20 years ago and
part of the process he was on education
and part of the process of coming up
with that formula and what he was
explaining to me was that
speaking about every they were dividing
it by District but it didn't mean the
students in the school
system districts but all students
all students who lived within that
District
was the number they were talking about
and they didn't Envision that it would
only be going to public school students
do you have a question and and so I'm
wondering well that conflicts with what
he's saying and I'm wondering
how your
determining that it's only public
schools and the only way that students
have to meet that require that
opportunity requirement is public
schools yeah I received that that
opinion from uh from an employee of the
department
further questions
not seeing any thank you very much thank
you Mr chair thank you members of the
committee uh by the way we do need a
pink card
thank you see it over here as a as a
pretty clear view yeah
yeah actually it does
thank you for the observation
represent cascadden are you going to
speak on this bill
okay
thank you Mr chair
um just wanted to provide more
information so that you can make an
educated decision on this bill as I am
also a co-sponsor of it so I am
representative Karine cascadden I
represent kowas County District 5 the
city of Berlin
um this is just more additional
information that people need to know
because unless you actually work in a
district or a system
you really don't know what
responsibilities lie within that whole
school district not just the buildings
themselves
and as a superintendent you are required
by federal laws to make sure that if
there are students that need Services of
any kind whether they are homeschooled
or in private schools that there is a
relationship
and I've had some very successful
parents who homeschool and they have
access to our programs at their choice
and need
um so I want to say that public schools
at the administrative level of a
district are required to extend and
offer the opportunity for all students
within that District even if they're not
enrolled in the public schools within
their school districts to participate in
any program course class any Services
co-curricular athletic programs at no
cost
um and at whatever parts or levels as
long as it is less than 50 percent of a
day because if they take one class over
you know that fifty percent then they
need to enroll as a student but they can
take up to say four courses a year and
earn high school credit
um at no additional
um
you know at no cost because it's already
in the system
and again this is partly paid by
property local property taxpayers my
concern is to watch out though
if someone wants some of these services
and is on a scholarship
but don't want those opportunities in
the public sector isn't that double
dipping
my next is on special ed services and
again there are multiple federal laws
from referral through process through
identification of all children that are
in need within the district it doesn't
matter if they're a homeschool student
if that parent suspects there's an issue
then their contact is that Local
District to see can you help me figure
this child out and what do I need to
provide or what do you need to provide
and so if a student or a parent
has a child already in a public school
system for example
and they were identified as a student
with a learning disability or in need of
related services and then that the
parent decides to send the child to a
private school which sometimes by the
way that is a joint team decision of the
public school team at the table with the
parent because we've paid tuition a
private we've paid tuition at Charter
and we've supported homeschool parents
at a district level
however if the child
has services in a public school and then
the parent goes to a private just an
example is on a scholarship and now
wants speech services
at the expense of the scholarship
taxpayer money it has already been
offered as a related service in the
public school at no cost other than the
cost to the taxpayers
but it means that that parent at some
point in the team meeting before they
withdrew signed a refusal of services
so that's important to know because if a
parent leaves the district after they've
been receiving services and they don't
want that speech therapist anymore they
don't want that academic intervention
for their dyslexia child or whatever
disability they have they are signing a
document that says I'm refusing services
and it doesn't make sense to me
to go someplace else get a scholarship
and now start looking for some private
therapist or online tutoring system to
meet that need that's double dipping a
property taxpayers so it's just
additional information that you need to
know this occurs at a district level
Administration have to have a
relationship with all private schools
and families so
that's all I have to say representative
thank you very much representative
representative Belcher
thank you Mr chair just to clarify
because it seemed that some of the
testimony may have conflicted with
things we've previously heard on efas
is it not true that schools and or
districts have the option of billing the
EFA program for these classes that EFA
students are taking at Public Schools
I'm not aware of that so I can't really
adequately answer that I'm sorry thank
you
foreign
thank you
um EFA students if they take a course at
a public school are required to pay for
that under there from their EFA account
it's specific in the statute that the
public school will not provide tuition
to that public school for for that
course
um but the the question is
um in relation to those Services
um that the child is leaving behind
um is possible I would think that
they're not getting the services that
they need in the public school and
that's the reason that they're looking
for either a tax credit scholarship or
an EFA program
because they are looking for
services that will meet their needs and
that EFA
account is still partially funded by
local tax dollars so they're using their
own tax dollars to provide that service
that they require so I'm not sure where
just so that I address what you're
saying
um
you know I can't address your answer but
I know
um
I know what you were saying I just drew
a blank again um is it possible that you
concluding with the homeschooler which
can get a you can Bill a 0.15 if we have
money available
right would the EFA child who's in a
different leg of the stool not we have
public private we have homeschooling
and we have right EFA
right so four separate types of meeting
the compulsory attendance right but then
again the the family that's receiving
the EFA if they are living within the
school district I mean I don't know what
the last two year policies are I'll be
honest I mean maybe you do and you can
share that but
um any child in Ace Public School
District has access to any of those
services
and if a parent says no I want a
Cadillac and you say well we can only
provide a Chevy
I mean what are you going to do
right the police restrictive environment
really is the law okay okay further
questions
yes representative Drive
thank you Mr chairman thank you could
you just from for my help can you show
me where
it's you have to extend the opportunity
to participate where that's found in
that's other students that students
within the district have that option to
take classes and courses correct where
would I find that in Local District
policies and maybe you could access or
reach out to um New Hampshire school
boards Association they would have a
model
we also have in co-curricular activities
it is and and and and the 0.15 for the
homeschooling parent that they're
required to extend them where they are
technological questions if they're space
available and the administration the
school says yes you can come and because
there's the potential for that high
school to receive reimbursement for the
time that the the homeschooler is in
attendance at the high school okay I
think at a 0.15 of the cost of uh
a school day basically
okay could represent like us
thank you thank you for taking my
question I'm still puzzled if the school
district has to provide these things to
anybody within the district even
homeschoolers and if EFA students are
required to pay for those things if they
get them out of their EFA money
I'm not sure why it matters where
they're coming from
whether it's a private school an EFA a
home school or the public school why
does it matter since you're providing It
Anyways wherever they are and if they're
EFA they have to pay for it so why does
it matter other than you're getting paid
well it's it's probably accountability
as well I can only speak that uh federal
law
you know has a set set process and you
know legal requirements on how that
process happens
and maybe rep um
Jen palmacato who's here on behalf of
nhsaa is a special ed specialist she may
be able to answer that better than I can
but special ed law is very specific
okay I'm gonna really try to get us back
on track because this particular bill is
not a bill that's open for questioning
on all the EFA areas we're dealing with
kindergarten first grade here and let's
keep it down to that because we could go
all day talking about efas but that's
not what we're here for on 4 30.
further questions for represent
welcome
thank you chairman
um my name is Edwin Osborne I'm a 15
year old homeschooler and a student at
Latitude learning resources which is a
homeschool Learning Center in Derry I
um several of the kids that attend this
Learning Center that I go to with that I
either I either work with them because
they're younger than me or I'm friends
with them because they're my age several
of them use the education Freedom
accounts because they just couldn't
they couldn't survive in public school
and they had like they had to get out of
there and they came to latitude and they
used that education Freedom account
money to do so
this bill if passed would prevent
non-current EFA students from attending
my Learning Center as well as other
similar places or a private school
anything else really that helps them get
out of public school because Public
School
damages children it's not a safe
learning environment I've talked to my
several of my friends and acquaintances
who have been in public school
and they've dealt with they've seen some
stuff they've heard some stuff it's just
overall not safe not
they don't learn as much as they should
and forcing someone to have that year of
public education under their belt before
they can apply for an for an education
Freedom account it's just not fair
that's um my testimony I'm open to
questions thank you very much other
questions from the committee
thank you for your trip here again today
okay that's the encouragement are there
any other cards for this bill
thank you very much everybody we're
yeah about a 10 minute break
we're ready to go on with the next bill
which we have in front of us as a note
for the committee I don't know if
everybody's aware where there's a water
cooler on this floor where if you want
to fill up a water bottle you may do so
from bottled water it's down in room 210
211 that's the finance room at the very
in the hallway as you go down you take a
left and the last door looks like an
office door it goes in sort of lunch
area where Finance people oftentimes eat
there's a bottle water cooler machine
right in there and if you want to fill
up a jug of water you can do it right
there nice cool water
so many people don't know that I had
explained that to represent luno here
last year and I think that's where he
feels is up to
you need a map that's right
okay so let's go ahead now with the next
bill on the dock there's HB 529 FN
this is relative to additional Aid
grants for schools based on free and
reduced price meals and fiscal capacity
disparity uh representative fellows uh
welcome
thank you chairman Ladd and education
committee members I'm I'm Sally fellows
I represent Plymouth holderness in
Hebron before I retired I worked at the
Department of Education for 30 years and
I worked with school funding formulas
and
um collection of student and school
Finance data and I also worked for a
couple of years as a business
administrator and at an SAU
I have I do have a little background
with um this sort of thing
so we have an education funding crisis
in New Hampshire property taxpayers have
no choice but to Bear 71 of the cost of
educating students in our local schools
because the state with a con which has a
constitutional responsibility to provide
an adequate education and pay for it
covers only about 21 percent of that
cost
there is no other state that downshifts
so much of the cost of Education onto
homeowners and small business owners in
the form of property taxes
and property taxes High property taxes
impact everybody in the community it
increases rental costs and it causes
some retirees to have to move out of
their homes because the taxes are so
high
this year's adequacy Aid includes a
hundred million dollar reduction to the
Statewide property tax which has lowered
property tax bills collectively across
the state by about 100 million dollars
but this is a one-time deal and it will
expire and property taxes will go back
up in December
so what hb20 529 does is it uses
approximately the same amount of money
and it's actually a little less and it
returns that money
um in a different format the current so
it's the same level of it cost to stay
the same but the money is distributed
differently there are two components to
this funding package one of them is
called fiscal capacity disparity Aid and
and compared to the current
um tax relief it shifts more Aid to
communities that have lower property
values
and the free and reduced meal Aid is
allocated based on the percentage of
students that are eligible for free and
reduced price meals and that is pretty
much a proxy measure for income wealth
since the LBA has not yet prepared a
fiscal note I used information from the
Doe's website the spreadsheet that they
have on there for the fy04
adequacy Aid allocation based on the
current law and I made modifications to
um there is a couple of things that I
need to tell you in on the bill let me
on the first page on line 20
there's drafting problem which is my
fault at the end of that line it should
say times the admr
because otherwise the municipality would
get the aid that one student is entitled
I think um
um thing that I can that I know of that
is an issue with the way that this is
drafted so I'd be happy to take
anybody's questions about the
spreadsheet or the formula or anything
else related to the bill representative
fellows are there any questions
yes representative Tanner
thank you and thank you for bringing
this forward
um could you just go back over that
correction and read the sentence to us
as it should be corrected so on the
first page on line 20
the whole sentence starts on line 18 and
it says a municipate municipality with
an equalized valuation per admr greater
than 600 000 but less than one million
0.002 cents for each dollar of
difference between the equalized
valuation per admr and one million six
hundred thousand dollars and what you
need to write in right after that is
times the admr so if you look up at line
16 and 17 it has pretty much the same
construction to it
both of them both of them have a per
pupil amount and then you
multiply that times the number of
further questions represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair
um so looking again at the the the
Supreme Court of New Hampshire and the
concept of an adequate education and
funding and adequate education
is there we already have a number of
programs that that would shift and
offset more State money to you could say
poorer communities communities of more
need
than communities that may be wealthier
is there ever a point that we could
shift so much relative funding from the
state to these poorer communities versus
wealthier communities that we might
actually be considered not adequately
funding an education in the wealthier
communities
I see I understand so I was following
you up in up until the end there are you
know there are many ways that the state
sends money to communities uh not just
for education for you know room and
meals tax distribution that kind of
stuff and the Constitutional
requirement is that that was determined
by The Claremont ruling which was about
20 years ago
said that it's the state's
responsibility to determine what is an
adequate education
figure out how much that costs
pay for it
and then it there's also a provision
that it should of our accountability you
know to make sure that that is actually
that the adequate education actually
it's opportunity for an adequate
education is actually happening
let me follow up just to clarify a
little little better I guess what I'm
getting at is given the I guess you
would call it a a progressive system
where we're more funding is shifted from
the state to the poorer communities
but we also have a responsibility to
relatively fund the wealthier
communities as well under that Supreme
Court decision correct oh okay so we're
just talking about education funding
correct oh
um yeah the constant that Claremont
um suit ruling
said that the state was responsible for
paying for an adequate education
and
I'm not I'm not a lawyer but my
interpretation of that would be
for every community
but it also
um does does not mean that the state has
to pay for every dollar either because
there could be things that go beyond
what what meets the definition of
adequate thank you
representative and just a quick look at
this bill right now this bill appears to
me to have a similar type process
um built upon what came out when
Jennifer Ford helped us back in 2018
with this
gradually down formula and now follow
through with current law is that correct
are we talking about the numbers look a
little bit different
but the process and the principle behind
this
is not a change is that correct I I
would you know I can't okay
so he'd talk about it when he gets up
yeah this because I didn't sponsor the
other Bill and and I'm and when was the
other Bill well this this is now it's
about five years later after we're not
we worked with Jeff for that was the
Karen umberger study
we came up with a formula like this
where you know it the when you get down
like 600 dollars per pupil equalized
property valuation you would get more
support and it would gradually filter
way to nothing and I I don't know I
can't remember was one point
two four million words it's it's stopped
it was something in that vicinity 2018
yeah it was 2018. so so representative
lad you know over the years over over
the the um I started work at the
Department of Education in 1985 and my
very first assignment was to use an IBM
PC to write an a distribution formula
for governor sununu and that would be
the first governor sununu and since then
you know every year there's been some
sort of proposal to change it and and
there are so many options and it never
ceases to amaze me we just keep going so
thank you very much representative
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
being here
so we've had I'm interested in your
history at the department dealing with
school aid
so we've had Claremont one Claremont 2
Londonderry Dover
in all those in all those Court
decisions they basically have said that
the current funding system is not fair
does not meet the Constitutional
requirement
would you concur with a statement that
the state
the legislature has yet
to comply
I would definitely agree that since
the state has although they responded to
the Claremont suit in 1999 has yet to
even come close to
doing what the Court ruling said we
needed to do thank you further questions
thank you Mr chair so follow-up to
representative miler's question
how much does this proposed Bill do to
address the reality of not having met
we are so far
meeting what the courts told us we
needed to do that it's almost like that
question isn't even relevant
but I can say what this formula does is
it's a Band-Aid it's a Band-Aid on a
system that has many
deficiencies and is bleeding in many
ways and this is just one Band-Aid on
dates all the way back to Senator
Estabrook and further
alrighty so any further questions
thank you very much
thank you for having me yep
thank you very much Mr chair and members
of the members of the committee for the
record Dave luno uh representing the
people of Merrimack County District 9
um who live in the towns of Bowen
Hopkinton
um I I don't have any prepared remarks
for today
um there was a lot of preparation that I
think went into this Rick and mellow
were both on this um and Dr cascadden on
this um uh uh school funding commission
which met during pretty much the whole
year of 2020 except for a few months
right at the beginning of the pandemic
we're trying to figure out how to do do
Zoom meetings securely and we conducted
most of our work nearly 200 hours of
public meeting and public comments and
and subcommittee meetings
remotely and it was tough
um uh but uh but we were able to
um to to publish a report in December of
2020. some of the numbers are out of
date but but most of this is policy
related recommendations and there may
still be copies of this report in the in
the office here
um if not I'd probably scare up a few
and there's also online it's available
online uh through the UNH car seat
school and I can provide anybody with
the um with the link to that but um but
um you know it was it was good to see
representative Schoenberg reference
reference this um uh this morning that
uh there's a lot uh to the um the
information in the report it covers a
wide variety of subjects everywhere from
from
um you know students and schools and
transportation and Technical education
and special education
and taxes and revenue sources and uh and
uh and the con belt suits uh sorry the
Claremont suits Claremont one two and
Londonderry and uh and so uh there were
a couple of attorneys on um on the
commission as well who weighed in
particularly on the those Supreme Court
opinions and I think some of the
questions that have come up today it
would be interesting to read what what
those attorneys both um both the
Republican and Democrat had to uh had to
say with respect to uh to the Supreme
Court rulings but I'm not going to spend
a whole lot of time on this I do want to
uh have a have a couple remarks on on
529 and a little bit of the case history
that that uh that chairman Ladd uh was
talking about
um very quickly though House Bill 529
make no mistake I mean actually I think
representative Damon's question was
right on it is not comprehensive school
funding reform it isn't even adequacy
it's built on top of adequacy so it
doesn't change the adequacy definition
doesn't change the costing out of
adequacy it it specifically puts in
place two uh two uh state grants that
we've had in place before a fiscal
capacity disparity Grant and then an
enhanced free and reduced price lunch
Grant whether that becomes a a
Medicaid direct certification Grant or
we can call it something else but um uh
but basically that that recognizes the
additional costs that uh that school
districts with with higher
concentrations of of low-income students
um uh in it so but um but quickly on the
on the commission when looking at
comprehensive reform uh the the
commission really came down in three
areas defining adequacy
representative Vlad talked about how you
know that comes right out of right out
of Claremont
um and defining adequacy in terms of
student performance
um the second piece is costing out
inadequate education what does it cost
to do that what does it cost to get that
that High student outcome that we're
also proud of here in New Hampshire top
five or six in the country so so I mean
we can argue other things but top five
or six in the country is certainly
something that that we can be proud of
um
uh here in New Hampshire and then the
third piece and uh and this is really
the important part and this is the part
that really falls out of the um uh you
know it's beyond defining adequacy and
costing adversely the third piece making
sure that every school district has
access to the resources they need
to fund their inadequate education for
all their students and um and and and
that's a really important point it's
important to look at that separately
because that's one of the one of the
main conclusions of the commission work
is that costing and funding are two
different things
um and um and we won't belabor that
today because that's not what this bill
is about but but that's what
comprehensive school funding
um is about so um we talked about it
early actually a couple times today New
Hampshire's adequacy is defined in 198
colon 40 a and uh and it recognizes that
um that uh that adequacy
um can be uh can be defined uh or can be
costed in terms of student outcomes
because that's exactly what our
differentiated Aid factors are and we've
got several we heard about one this
morning with um with third grade reading
so that's a factor English language
which learning is a factor special
education is a factor and free and
reduced price lunch concentrations as a
proxy for low-income populations in the
district that's a factor so we know that
that there are that that there are there
probably using the word wrong
um uh extent
extending extensive extenuating factors
that that that lead to costs that a
district would incur to educate all of
its all of its students
um but um but and and and and and and
House Bill 529 does try to get at one of
those factors particularly the um the
the low income Factor
um so uh the um
uh it's it's also I think important to
share a little bit about what our
neighbors to the South do because
they're also in that sort of top five
you know
um of student performance nationally but
Massachusetts doesn't Implement a uh a
definition of adequacy based on student
outcomes or recognizing that uh that
that schools and and
um and and the students there are aren't
you know uh you know are it doesn't
recognize that they're different you
know it's it's different Wellesley than
it is in Lawrence and so so
Massachusetts has much more of a flat
funding type of model and actually New
Hampshire's funding model is largely
flat funding except for that little bit
of you know you know
um uh differential Aid uh and um
and what Massachusetts is finding out
from that is that student achievement
across these districts varies widely so
um so so they haven't been able to solve
the um the student achievement or the
student Equity Gap they've solved the
taxpayer Equity Gap we haven't solved
either one of those things in our in our
current model we've got taxpayer
um you know well you know the report
sums it up pretty clearly that New
Hampshire school funding formula fails
both taxpayers and students across the
state and I think we're going to hear a
little bit about
um a little bit about that
um
but um back to 529
um it's not comprehensive reform as
representative fellows said
it's really you know it's really a light
touch
um it's a it's a hundred million dollars
almost 100 million dollars uh but that's
100 million dollars out of 3.2 billion
dollars that we spend here in New
Hampshire if you want comprehensive
reform in New Hampshire you take what
the state spends
um uh and um and you know
use that as a as a number that you that
you invest
um in in costing out inadequate
education and making sure that districts
have the access to the resources they
need so in this case it's using part of
that hundred million dollars
specifically about 70 million 80 million
dollars sorry uh to make sure that
districts have access to the resources
they need you know I think um mayor
Craig from Manchester would probably say
that Manchester could use that whole 80
million dollars itself and even with
that it wouldn't uh and representative
Cornell would certainly agree with that
and even with that they wouldn't come up
to the average per pupil spending
anywhere close to the average per pupil
spending that um that we've got here
that we heard from representative
Schoenberg this morning so um House Bill
529 is something that that we think
could be possible this year and you know
obviously we've got a very challenging
session we've got really tight tight
numbers but I think I think you know uh
people on both sides of the aisle are
certainly representing constituents that
that feel the pressure of property taxes
and are looking for some some relief and
um and 529 does that the biggest part of
529 is is is uh is is tax relief that's
the 80 million dollar part
um on that
um and it has a sliding scale we'll get
into that shortly the um
um it also recognizes that uh that there
are extenuating factors particularly the
free the the low income factor and it
directs 17 million dollars towards uh
towards districts with higher
concentrations of um of uh of uh
students from from you know low-income
households and so this is actually a
very similar to Senate Bill 420 which we
passed last year which um by the way I
think had a um had very close to a 17
million dollar
um uh
enhance reintroduced price price lunch
component to it so so House Bill 529
essentially doubles that extraordinary
needs Grant and um and
and it also you know it it doesn't it
doesn't do 529 doesn't do this but we're
going to hear another bill in a few days
uh House Bill 540 uh which is um uh
co-sponsored by by Representatives lad
Miler uh cordelian Ward uh that that
actually recognizes recognize additional
costs so you know extenuating needs
associated with special education so
these are all part of a a package of
bills that uh that are designed to move
us all move New Hampshire in the right
direction when it comes to Equitable
school funding so now I just want to
swing over to um House Bill 709 which uh
which the chair had had referenced
earlier uh this was something that we
worked on collaboratively back in 2019
uh the bill was filed and Mark was in
the LBA across the street yeah yeah we
worked with with with uh with Nikki on
and Mark and Mickey on on that and they
put together miles and miles of uh of
spreadsheets for us as we're trying out
different um different scenarios but uh
but we came up with uh with a scenario
very similar to this the splits are
about about the same the um
the um the starting point and end point
have been updated so I think back then
it was like 350 000 was low equalized
value per pupil going to 1.1 million
dollars was the high equalized property
value per pupil that has shifted to six
hundred thousand dollars at the low and
1.6 million at the high so that
represents current equalized uh Mark you
know change in market value over the
last uh four years and the 1.6 is
actually the average equalized valuation
um uh in the state and so it provides
that 80 million dollars to support
districts on a sliding scale uh that
have lower than average uh equalized
property values because they can't they
can't generate the local property tax
revenue to fund their schools some are
working super hard like like
um like well I only just pick one like
Hopkinton all right because I know it
really well and and we spent and
something close to thirty dollars per
thousand on our schools
um and on our tax rate which is a really
high
um School tax rate New Hampshire
haverhill's right up there uh with it
too I think pretty close to that
yeah yeah I'll look it up yeah and uh
but uh but but
Hopkinton student outcomes are also
among the best in the state and we're
working hard and we're getting results
but we only have to go 20 minutes up the
road to Newport
they're working super hard I think their
school tax rate is almost forty dollars
35 or 40 dollars per thousand and even
at that they can't generate a um a
reasonable uh amount of local tax Rec
Revenue to fund a a school budget and um
and you know I I always throw Manchester
under the bus on on here but actually
Newport has the lowest performing
students in the state
highest taxes lowest performing that's
where House Bill 529 comes in and really
delivers some cash to provide some tax
relief uh to Newport but also some
Revenue to Newport that they can put
towards their budget not every not every
school district's going to need need you
know you can use it for tax relief you
can use it for Revenue but it helps to
write the ship for these um for these
districts
um House Bill 709
all right it uh it uh it passed this
committee
do I have to vote on here
past this committee
there was um two floor amendments
a committee Amendment and then the Luna
loud amendment that I think was probably
some housekeeping in that in that bill
that both passed with a Voice vote
and then on February 27 2019
the bill is amended past the floor of
the house on a roll call vote of 262 to
82.
so pretty strong by it was one of the
strongest bipartisan votes uh I think we
had in that in that session and I think
that speaks to the
reason why
Hospital 709 and now House Bill 529
um really do meet the needs of most of
of our constituents
um uh across the state
um
so it's um
what was the problem with household 709
why aren't we just living the dream and
and uh going with that because
um what what ended up happening and what
what may happen with this bill too
um is uh is if it passes here and passes
the floor and goes to finance Finance
can take a look at putting it in the
state budget and uh and the wording in
the state budget uh during that year was
that it was only going to last for one
year so it was only in the FY 21 budget
so so the grants that came out of out of
out of household 709 which came came to
somewhere in the 62 to 65 million dollar
range total lasted only one year for the
2020-2021 school year fiscal year 21.
um and uh and that was a problem
um uh we heard about it from mayor Craig
actually because um what what cities
like Manchester need is sustainable
Revenue Source from the state a
predictable State funding stream again
comprehensive school funding reform but
even something like this if it can go in
as a multi-year plan than than at least
cities and towns can know what's coming
at them and can form their budgets and
have a predicted and and a sustainable
solution uh and that's what house bill
529 uh does but most importantly and
this is the part I don't want anybody to
forget I'm sorry I'm spending so much
time on this
um is that it uses the same amount of
money that's in the current FY 23
education trust fund for supporting
Public Schools doesn't use any more
use the same amount of money that we're
currently using out of the education
trust fund so
um I guess in conclusion
um uh representative Belcher has
mentioned that a couple times we've got
um we've we've we've got a lot of stuff
in the rear review window Claremont
Claremont one Claremont to Londonderry
we've got conval in front of us right
now we've got the Rand case pending and
passing House Bill 529 I think would be
a strong sign to the courts that the
legislature can get something done uh in
school funding it's not perfect it's not
comprehensive it's a light touch but
that we take it seriously and we take
this job seriously and um and and I hope
that the courts will uh will con will
will allow the legislature to um to to
do what it's supposed to do Define
adequacy cost it out and then make sure
that every district has the access to
the resources they need because if they
don't where I I don't know what's going
to happen so I think 529 is a is a shine
as a sign of good faith effort that that
we can live up to our obligations to so
with that I'll wrap up and happy to take
any questions on any of this stuff other
questions yes reptek has guided thank
you Mr chair thank you representative
lulo uh luno just a question of
technicality would say if this were
passed it would only take effect July 1
2024 is there any rationale why it
wouldn't take effect July 1 2023 sure
thank you for the thank you for the
question
um uh yeah because the school budgets
and budget committees are already
working on their their their their their
uh their FY 24 budgets and um and you
know
and it's going to take a while
if this were to pass and get everywhere
it needs and everything uh it's not
going to be on on anybody it's not going
to be on the governor's desk until the
end of June so um so so fy25 becomes a
practical
um a practical thing
thank you for the question
representative leckis
thank you thank you for taking my
question
I remember that subcommittee and and
um I thought we came out with some
some good ideas out of that and one of
the things I'm wondering one of the
things we did is this
529 has those
water you know Cliffs that you fall over
between here and here you get this
between here and here you get this Etc
and one of the things we did was we made
a linear function instead of a step
function and we got help from the
numbers people who said yeah no problem
so that was one of the things I thought
was particularly good about 709 and I'm
wondering why that wasn't done then in
529 yeah so so thanks I'm not sure we
actually did that in 709
um
um I I know exactly what you're talking
about and and we actually did it in
House Bill 1680 last year we had a we
had a smoothing function particularly
for the free introduced price lunch
um uh grants this one does have a smooth
function on the fiscal capacity
disparity Aid the larger of the two
grants the 80 million dollars that's a
that's a fraction of a penny per dollar
for every um every student in the ADM so
so that has a a absolutely smooth
um um Landing path between
districts with a valuation of six
hundred thousand dollars per pupil and
1.6 million dollars per people it's
completely linear uh on that but but
thank you very much
um representative Lucas for bringing
that up because I think we're we're you
know as as representative fellow said uh
we've got some we've got some
housekeeping a housekeeping Amendment
anyway let's take a look at doing that
for the free and reduced price lunch I
love that idea thank you thank you yes
the free and reduced as you remember
back in 2008 nine thereabouts when we
we got into the report of establishing
adequacy then we had the waterfall
effect you go from this bracket uh free
and reduced to this bracket and each
there was no slide it was just you
dropped off so if you went from let's
say I'll just grab a number from 20 to
19 if you're at the Costco one you took
a real drop in one year of what kind of
Revenue we're going to get and and that
was not really a sustainable picture at
all for school districts to plan
based upon the number of kids that came
in free and reduced each year it might
flip-flop on them and there they are
they're losing thousands of dollars yeah
yeah no I think that's a great it's a
great suggestion for for this I think
we'll move in that direction well that
was the concept came out of the 2018
report too as you just have this slide
right yeah
yes representative woodcock
thanks chairman it was a little thank
you for taking my two questions one far
one question two Posse
um how many communities will this impact
I'm gonna say at least over half
um uh probably probably much more than
that probably more like two-thirds or
three quarters uh uh but uh but
everybody has a uh yeah yeah so but that
but yes may follow up yes thank you and
you know babe is this going to be annual
is this going to be embedded in for Left
for a good so
um the way the language is written in
529 it would be there until it's
repealed or changed
um but um but as we know this isn't the
last stop sure first and last stop for
this bill and um but the intent is
ongoing yes okay thank you thank you Mr
chairman but this remember is not part
of the adequacy right and that's that's
the issue because everything there forth
is a grant okay and grants get changed
just just like the the extraordinary
needs Grant is is there right now yeah
but but but but the bill that you're
sponsoring
540 that actually is an adequacy that's
Amendment that's different than this but
it taken together its school funding yes
yes thank you both
uh further questions we have a few more
cards on 529 here
they come in order here there
is 309
hello again uh for the record my name is
Zach Sheehan I'm the Project Director of
the New Hampshire school funding
fairness project uh we are in support of
House Bill 529
[Music]
um
largely uh the reason being that does
touch upon two of the main inequities in
our school funding system those of the
funds being distributed to schools and
who pays for them
um
in support 529 because it does consider
the varying abilities of communities to
raise sufficient funds for the public
schools in this system
Additionally the proportion of students
in any given District to qualify for
free and reduced price meals is an
important equity-minded approach to
increasing aid for schools that need it
most and by combining these two
additional Aid calculations House Bill
529 acknowledges that communities can
have on average higher property values
and still have students different
proportions of students that might have
different needs as measured by amount of
free reduced price lunch students
um but such communities do have are
forced to rely so heavily on local
property taxes to fund our schools the
equalized value for people is a good
measure the community's relative fiscal
capacity to support their schools and
add Aid waited to consider that capacity
is critical to help schools that need it
most
um and I do have some testimony passing
around but just pulled out a few
examples
um for folks specifically so if you look
at two two towns um
Milford and Portsmouth for example they
have similar student populations Milford
has an equalized value for people of
just over a million dollars in any
classical tax rate of about fourteen
thousand dollars fourteen dollars per
thousand which raises about fourteen
thousand dollars per student but
Portsmouth on the other hand has the
acquires value for people of um four
times that about four million dollars an
equalized School tax rate about five
dollars per thousand and if they raise
twenty one thousand dollars per student
so while the people in Milford pay
almost three times the school property
tax rate than those in Portsmouth
they raised six thousand dollars less
per student due to the dramatic
differences in their average property
values and that's just one example
um you can see that all throughout the
state and so I think that taking
equalized value for pupil is House Bill
529 does into account as the community's
different communities relative fiscal
ability to raise funds uh since about 70
percent of all School District revenue
does come from local property taxes this
is a good step in the right direction
um to making our school funding system
more Equitable I'll be happy to help
respond to the disability committee if
you have any suggestions or proposed
changes or anything and I'd be happy to
answer any questions thank you for the
questions
now seeing thank you very much
Paul uh grandma
is it the g-r-e-m
B I'm thinking I know I'm just trying to
think
I don't know
Graham Ranger
bro
thank you that's quite all right
chairman Ladd it's always a pleasure to
see you it seems like I see you every
two years yes
I got a prepared statement that I have
one going around for all the committee
members
uh dear Chapman lad and members of the
House Education committee uh my name is
Paul Grenier and I am currently serving
in my 14th consecutive year as mayor of
the city of Berlin
I want to thank you for your work in
serving our great state in times that
are both very challenging but also quite
rewarding I'm in front of you today to
ask all of you to support
House Bill 529 as I read the text of the
bill it is clear that the intent of the
bill is to Target additional State
education Aid that to communities that
have a disproportionate number of
students in public schools that come
from economically struggling families
the rapidly skyrocketing cost of housing
in our state even in Berlin
has created a dynamic where even working
families at once could get by now find
themselves struggling week to week just
to feed their families
in Berlin as of the October 2022
Department of Education report a
fraction of over 46 percent of our total
student population
qualify for free and reduced lunch
those are the faces of kids that are the
future of our region State and Workforce
just as important however is this burden
creates a huge backlash for our already
stretched taxpayers in Berlin
high-paying jobs are not the norm and
many residents who own their homes are
retired
Berlin's local school funding debates
don't Center on new athletic fields or
new intramural intramural activities
which we all know are Out Of Reach
it comes down fairly quickly to how much
we can afford
with limited local resources many kids
who struggle badly wind up being left
out
in addition gifted kids who need to be
challenged often don't get the proper
attention they truly deserve
House Bill 529 though not perfect at
least attempts to address the inequities
that have long been identified by our
court system
I would suggest however that the bill be
amended to raise equalized valuation per
admr to read 850 000 or less
you may find that there are no school
districts who follow that category with
the current proposed language
in closing along for the day I no longer
have to testify in education related
bills
Berlin is climbing out of the depot we
found ourselves in to be in 16 years ago
I also plead with all of you to find a
permanent solution to funding education
that removes The Cloud of uncertainty
school districts and municipalities face
every two years
most importantly
find a solution before the New Hampshire
courts impose one on all of us
that is not the New Hampshire way
glad to take questions thank you very
much other questions for the city
manager of city mayor mayor right
Berlin
you mentioned 850 000 is that we're
going to start with this why I think the
bill says 600 000 and work and the the
the the top one point the poorest number
is 600 000 in reviewing uh Brolin's
figures right now with our new
reevaluation
our our net value per student is around
000 dollars
but that's counting uh electrical
generating assets within the city of
Maryland's attacks and as we all know
generating assets don't pay local school
tax they pay the state uh School tax so
if you take 25 percent of Maryland's
taxable valuation now we're down to
about 510 520 000 per student
herein lies one of the larger inequities
of the law and totality
okay thank you further further questions
welcome
thank you Mr chairman and committee uh
my name is Sean Parr I'm on the
Manchester School Board where I sit on
the policy committee and chair the
education legislation committee today
I'm speaking on behalf of the Manchester
School Board which has authorized me to
advocate for additional support to
individual schools and districts with
higher proportions of students in
poverty English language Learners and
students receiving special education
services
we are therefore unanimous in our
support of the targeted funding proposed
in HB 529 as of December 31st 2022 our
applications for free or reduced price
meals make 51.18 of our students
eligible
in addition to being chronically
underfunded our district our district
projects food costs to increase
significantly due to shortages in food
and supplies bid prices that reflect
inflation and Workforce shortages in
schools and in the transportation of
supplies I would also point out that in
addition to being the largest school
district in the state with 12 300
students Manchester is also the most
diverse District in the state with
nearly half of our students being
non-white
many of our minority students come from
the city's Refugee population and
reflect a wide variety of cultures this
demographic fact informs not only the
importance of supporting these students
with nutritious food but also with food
choices that are sensitive to their
religions and cultures offering these
choices is often more expensive but we
are committed to doing so because it is
the right and respectful policy
diversity is one of our great strengths
and we want to support all of our
students for these reasons the
approximately 13 million dollars of
additional State funding that this bill
would provide is urgently needed and we
ask for your support thank you for your
consideration thank you very much are
there any questions for the Manchester
we have gone through all the cards we
have up here for 529
with that I'm going to close this
hearing
I will announce to the committee here
that we will have a work session next
week I don't have the exact time down
but count on a work session for 5 29 and
601.
okay so what time we have here
you know five minutes okay it's 3 15 for
okay
yeah I'm gonna just take a break myself
for a second here
uh for those that have to get up and
take a break we're going to take a five
minute break right here now and then we
will come back and start this up at
okay
I start our hearing on HB 309 FN this is
relative to civil rights education and
public elementary and secondary schools
I'd like to welcome representative ulrey
thank you Mr chair this is a lot better
than talking about taxes
[Laughter]
rather long and boring today but uh for
the record my name is Jordan uldery I'm
here uh representing Hillsboro 13 on
House Bill 309 FN this uh primary bill
is uh part of a larger Nationwide uh
process
that uh regarding teaching civil rights
education in schools there's a couple of
programs McGraw-Hill which is one of the
Publishers of this book which has been
talking about the legacy of Martin
Luther King Jr and what
those of us of a certain age remember
taking place quite vividly some in their
own neighborhoods I grew up at that time
in Elkhart Indiana and some of you may
remember that a former president went to
Elkhart because of its
um problems it was having with uh race
I decided to sponsor this after seeing
this at a couple of national conferences
I have emailed to the committee several
pieces of literature and something under
the title of testimony and I'm hoping
that representative lattice chair you
went through those emails into the the
public record
I would greatly appreciate that
those of us who have been around for
more than one or two years remember what
uh Martin Luther King said on the mall
in front of uh the Lincoln Memorial
about judging people according to their
character
I'm not going to to try and come
anywhere near his eloquence in speaking
but he did mention New Hampshire
specifically in that famous speech
he's talking about from the hills the
White Mountains of New Hampshire to the
red clay of Georgia
one thing we haven't done here in New
Hampshire is actually addressed what he
asked to teach people how to cooperate
as one another yes he was a Christian
pastor and that I believe is from where
his philosophy our race relations came
those of us who are Christians recall
that we treat one another as we would
like to be treated
and that is what this legislation talks
about in his famous speech
Dr King also spoke about the fact that
yeah things happened bad things happened
but we can't dwell on the past we have
to act for the future
and we have to behave as though we're
heading towards
what he called the time when we can
judge one another and for those reasons
I've introduced this bill
I will say that for the record I don't
have any interest except maybe hidden in
some mutual fund about which I have no
idea uh you know with McGraw-Hill or any
of their Publications I have become
friendly with the primary sponsor
Matthew Daniels of this uh who's pushing
this Nationwide this bill has been
adopted in several States including
Colorado
and that's not exactly a red state
California again not exactly a red state
Texas
um I'll give you that one
but
ah and several of the southern states
have also adapted it including the Red
Hills of Georgia and the neighboring
state of Alabama both of whom had a
rather interesting Civil Rights era
history
ah and with that the Bill's pres has
been presented
it talks about
how to treat one another and how to
factually express
what has happened in history
as an event that took place and not a
sign blame on it but talk about how to
prevent it from happening ever
again
and I'll be happy to answer any
questions
thank you very much are there questions
from the committee yes represent Hall
sure thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question I know it says
that the department
um feels like they need to hire a
part-time employee to oversee
um this requirement and I noticed that
you know it says in the language state
board shall make available to all School
boards instructional materials is that
what is this person doing this part-time
employee they just what are they doing
there are quite a few employees in
several agencies in this state that I
would like to give the same answer to I
have no idea
however in this particular instance I
would presume to think that they would
oversee the presentation their
acquisition of the material the
presentation the material and assist in
the training of individuals in
presenting the material to the classes
thank you further questions
representative Allison uh thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
uh on lines uh 11-13 in the bill uh it
talks about a number of
events that must be coach shall not be
limited to must be covered uh the
Holocaust and that goes on from there
are you aware that the commission on
Holocaust and general side studies has
been in effect now for the last year and
a half and instruction in New Hampshire
schools is required and was required as
of September 1st and in fact curriculum
has been developed and is being
implemented in middle school and high
schools on almost all of those issues
that are right there already
yes and that's why it's there
it's already it's already part of uh
state law so therefore we're reaffirming
it in state law
thank you
further questions from the committee
representative Tanner
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
um you you referenced McGraw-Hill
um as one one group that had curriculum
did is there a specific curriculum uh
that's um
that's with this particular
um Civil Rights Movement from 54 to 68 I
mean that that uh
just deals with that particular part of
the American history
assaults yes there is a McGraw-Hill has
that in Hispanic adopted by several
state agencies already and it is my
understanding although I've had no
direct input into it but the Department
of Education is in the process of
reviewing that uh literature and
presenting it to the Board of Education
foreign
yes you may
um do you have a name of that curriculum
Martin Luther King civil rights
education okay thank you
further questions
yes represent Alexis
just making sure I understand
while that is a program that you know is
out there you're not actually
um pushing for any particular program
right you're leaving it up to local
choice to decide how they're going to
implement this is that correct
that's correct uh representative Lakers
and is that you're aware in our local
high school uh this is uh to some degree
already taught uh based upon uh broadly
the same activities this is just merely
uh placing it the law and aspect of a
methodology uh which should be
implemented in each one of the schools
so that people are aware of what took
place and
why Dr King made his his speech
um
frankly I would mandate that every
student be required to listen to it but
that's not going to happen but anyway
thank you
further questions representative Belcher
thank you Mr chair
I certainly would agree that the items
listed on here are are excellent
teaching topics and they're things that
all students should should know and
learn from history but the manner in
which they're taught also I think is is
important
um so I'm hoping you can assuage any
concerns I may have that some of the
more modern groups we see popping up who
are for instance
um uh dismissing the legacy of dot Dr
Martin Luther King in favor of promoting
um for instance the Black Panther Party
as the true inheritors of the Civil
Rights Act
um how can we how can I be certain that
this isn't something that's going to be
uh potentially hijacked as a vehicle for
foreign
talks about the principles in which Dr
King was presenting
the uh if you read speech
um I would if the chair once I have the
speech dot up here I can go ahead and
give it but if not it's okay too but he
talks about how we can cooperate and
where the he uses the term in his speech
the Negro has to uh forsake violence in
order to work with and
the also says where the white person has
to understand that they're part and
parcel of the same Legacy as is the
Negro
um and that's just a factual statement
in history
how can you prevent something from being
hijacked
it's not necessarily that you can
prevent anything from being hijacked you
can take a bill talking about the Pledge
of Allegiance and someone's going to say
well no no no that was created by a
socialist
oh it was but that's not what it is now
uh stopping something from happening is
do
to the due diligence of uh
the legislature the Board of Education
and the individual that they would hire
to oversee the programming and the local
school boards and local communities
I need to have a participation of
parents you need to have participation
for the school board in this type of
activity that's where at the local level
where you can maintain this and that's
where due diligence comes into play
thank you for your question
representative woodcock thank you
chairman good afternoon thank you for
taking my question I'm looking at the
bill I'm particularly online three and
four basically the that's the essence of
the bill
if I if I read your bill correctly
you're correct sir okay so is it um your
opinion then that uh under the current
U.S history classes that are being
taught in public high schools today in
New Hampshire that's not included it's
not included to the detail in which it
probably should be included I'm aware
and I do some uh uh I know lecturing
would not be the right word but uh uh
sit down and discuss in certain uh
classes at Auburn High School on
occasion and uh this is not a primary
topic because uh it it just isn't a
primary topic uh whereas I believe that
particular error
era
had uh well it had a strong impact on me
I would got caught up in a couple of
different events and in different
communities in which uh I found myself
at different times uh in Chicago and in
uh and in Elkhart
plus I also
uh had friends and and down that lived
down a while family lived down in
Detroit so very aware of what was going
on very aware of the activities
if I might Mr chair could relate an
incident that took place in Harlem
Kentucky
um many of you know that my mother's
family is from there Harlem bloody
Harlan if you will for a variety of
different reasons and moonshine was part
of it
but it's an Apple watch
spin
it was no problem for the youngsters to
go out and swim in the Cumberland River
not exactly a good idea considering it
was a Class D River at the time but you
know it's hot summer day you go out you
swim with it it made no difference who
we were and then the difference showed
up
dad why are there two drinking Fountains
at the Town Hall
and it didn't make any sense to me
doesn't make any sense to me now deck up
corrected
and the the strength of the species the
the speeches that took back effect at
the time the difference between Malcolm
X
and Martin Luther King's approach where
one was advocating violence and the
other was advocating understanding in a
Christian approach
I chose the Christian approach
just I love you thank you so basically
the antenna hour then is just to add
what is it's already in most public
school curricula so you're you're a
tenth of the bill just to make that more
reinforced in the curriculum
yes sir thank you thank you Chevrolet
I'd like to follow along with represent
woodcock's line of thinking
um we know that in this state
instruction curriculum are a local
concern by Statute
have you taken the time to do a Beyond
alverne
to take out a Statewide search or review
by way of various associations be it the
social studies Association to determine
if this is needed
and or what is being taught within
schools so we are going to if we're
going to mandate something which this is
then we're doing it because we see it's
not just a a local concern but a concern
Statewide
no sir I don't have the individual
resources nor do any of us have the
resources to undertake that on our own
however I am aware that the uh
Commissioner of education is is
reviewing the different aspects that
have taken place in this and has
discussed this on a Statewide basis I
leave that to the Department of
Education to undertake that type of
activity I will say that from uh their
my contacts at Albert High School uh the
impact on this is It's haphazard at best
and this gives guidance to the school
boards for their local input is to how
it goes this says this needs to be
included that's all it says
this needs to be included it doesn't say
it's going to be taught this way but it
says these things need to be examined in
some detail not glossed over not uh
given uh follow up then if in fact
you're identifying this in this school
district has there been any effort made
with the school board for them to
mandate that this becomes part of
curriculum
um not right now they're trying to put
in some security systems and uh their
their impact is uh
been regarding uh adding an auditorium
adding a stage expanding the size of the
high school and
um putting in a new uh uh driveway
entryway security system uh regarding
the educational aspects those are a
little bit further down on the board of
thank you very much for the questions
representative Tanner
I'm kind of concerned and wonder why uh
since I lived through that time as well
um that others that it was a Civil
Rights era but it wasn't just
um for the black people it was a gay
rights uh era it was a women's rights
era and
um
there's a lot of lessons to be learned
there as well and I'm I am wondering why
we're just picking you know Cherry not
only that it's telling curriculum which
I don't think should happen but it's
it's taking a curriculum and it's cherry
picking and just a certain part of the
Civil Rights era
well there's those are three uh
different things and that they were uh
contiguous but they weren't quite in the
same era the so the uh uh women's right
amendment that came forward is talking
about an equality and gender which is
substantially different than race
relations and the gay rights uh are came
in towards the uh uh I forget when the
the name of the club that was rated by
the New York police that uh that's one
that that came forward and again that's
uh a difference of uh not equipment they
should not be equilocated with the uh
civil rights or the race relations
um error
rights belong to people
as individual rights they and this
particular one talks about the
Discrimination that took place because
of a person's skin color or because of a
bias and and uh in that area now
when you address the prime this part as
a primary one and I don't mean to
denigrate women they're 50 of the
population or or gays that you know
that's that's in the family as well uh
but those issues become ameliorated when
you address the larger
if you will issue of race relations
because if you can learn to treat
the guy sitting next to you
equally you can learn
individually to treat a woman or
your gay guy at the bar that's sits
there and makes
I'm just thinking of a person who he was
making stupid jokes at the local bar but
uh
yes you may I I'm looking at the
statement that's the study of this
material is a reaffirmation of the
commitment of free peoples of this state
to reject bigotry to Champion equal
protection under the law as a
foundational principle of our Republic
and to act in opposition to Injustice
when wherever it may occur and
certainly the civil rights movement that
embodied the women's rights movement and
the gay rights movement was a part of
that and I
fundamentally don't understand how race
relations solves the problem of
homophobia and misogyny so
um you know
I guess that's I still don't understand
why it isn't part of that whole career
are there further questions of represent
ulrey
now see thank you very much thank you Mr
chair uh next person speak is Turin
oh you got me
c-a-k-i-r-a-g-a
foreign
or or a professional person I'm just uh
here to uh to oppose a part of the and
the bill
this is a a noble bill I I really
appreciate the uh that we all
have we all oppose the the
Discrimination definitely but there's a
section in the bill that is that talks
about the Armenian Genocide
and that's that is
a more than a hundred year old debate
that
I feel does not really
and belong to
uh to to introduce a youngest youngsters
events that took lucky during World War
One so after more than 100 years old 100
years we are still debating a weird
trying to
add something as speculative
to this build and uh you know did this
idea of a so-called genocide is is
really accepted by a United Nations or
or a world court or anything like that
even though some countries like ours
have accepted that this
event occurred multiced have
according to to the knowledge that I
know both sides have suffered
tremendously so I don't
if you're comfortable
including this kind of conspicuous of
information and and
introducing introducing this kind of a
uh speaker the information to our
youngsters especially
uh you know middle schoolers or uh
or younger youngsters
and because uh this is the perfect way
to to
introduce our our ideas whether they're
wrong or
correct
is first way to uh
have have
all our youngsters and
Bully each other and and I feel that
that we should include in anything like
this
thank you very much are there any
not seeing thank you very much
a next uh person is bear Christina
um
thank you chairman Ladd good afternoon
members of the committee bear Christina
from the New Hampshire school boards
Association uh we are opposed to House
Bill 309
um I appreciate representative's
explanation as to how and why this bill
came about there are certainly a
laudable expectations of what should be
taught in our schools
however nhsba has a couple long-standing
resolutions
um as we've talked about with
representative moffett's Bill about
teaching communism in schools one of our
resolutions states that local school
boards have the responsibility for
establishing the structure
accountability advocacy and delivery of
instruction within their local districts
also
nhsba supports the affirmation of the
responsibility of for Education resides
with the states and have delegated to
Local School boards the power and
authority to adopt policies establish
priorities and provide account abilities
so on and so forth another aspect is an
RSA 189 colon 1-A which at hsba wrote
with chairman Ladd a number of years ago
elected School boards shall be
responsible for establishing the
structure accountability advocacy and
delivery of instruction in each School
operating governed by the school
district so will nhsb certainly
recognizes that the state has a
responsibility to establish the
substantive content of an adequate
education as found in RSA 193e colon 2
the delivery of that instruction at HSB
nhsba believes is best left to the local
school districts to develop their own
curriculum their own coursework so on
and so forth two other aspects that I'll
I'll mention in nhsp's opposition to
this bill
the first is that we see a lot of bills
being put in RSA 189 189 is an
overarching statute relative to school
boards and a lot of responsibilities
that school boards have there's a number
of Provisions colon one through colon I
think we're up to I don't know 73 or
something like that now and hsba would
argue that if we're going to be putting
curricular content within statute it
needs to go in the adequacy statute RSA
193-e and then the back end of that is
the state has an obligation to pay for
it the state has an obligation
constitutional obligation to pay for the
content of an adequate education so by
continuing to put these Provisions in
RSA 189 the state is obvious
ignoring its responsibility to pay for
it instead of putting it in RSA 193
colon e or Dash e the adequate education
statute we might still object if it were
put in RSA 193e but it'd be a little bit
more palatable from a school board
provision because we know we'd be
getting it'd be included in the adequacy
formula the other aspect that this
curriculum should be very very mindful
of this session is that I think
everybody knows that the Department of
Education through the State Board of
Education is in the um in the midst of
doing a very comprehensive review to
Department of Education role Ed 306 the
minimum standards
um for public school approval that rule
is about 80 pages long it's a six-point
font without everything that a school
district has to do curricular course
offerings curricular standards policies
by school boards graduation minimum
graduation requirements so on and so
forth so we know that over the next I'd
say probably my best estimation would be
six to eight months the State Board
through their processes is undergoing a
complete revision of department of
educational 306 again the minimum
standards what our districts have to do
and offer and provide
by adding these curricular components to
statute outside of the minimum stand
outside of the adequacy statute excuse
me there's inevitably going to be some
conflict moving forward between what the
final outcome of the minimum standards
revisions which I'm guessing is going to
take another six eight months maybe a
year versus whatever pending legislation
we may get coming out of this Committee
in the New Hampshire legislature so for
those reasons nhfba opposes this bill
not because of the content but because
of sort of all of our long-standing
resolutions about nhsba posing the the
legislature dictating what curriculum
should be taught within our local school
districts so and with that I'm happy to
answer any questions thank you very much
are there any questions just
representative Belcher
thank you Mr chair
um
I heard you say that
um local school boards should be
primarily tasked with developing
curriculum
um can you tell me approximately to what
degree local school boards are currently
developing their own curriculum versus
obtaining that curriculum from outside
organizations and sources yeah thank you
very much for the question
representative we had a lot of
conversations last year didn't we about
school board oversight relative to
curriculum when you say you know outside
of organizations I'm not exactly sure
what you mean I heard your comment to
the to the the um the prime the prime
sponsor earlier so I get this just of
what you're getting at you know the the
school boards are I mean they're
ultimately responsible for the
curriculum in the sense that they're the
elected officials at the end of the day
the buck stops with the with the elected
officials relative to the school board
the elected official the elected School
Board school boards are not necessarily
involved in adopting curriculum per se
um most of the time
um to the extent the school board does
adopt its own curriculum or it's coming
from a rise of recommendation from an
administrator a curriculum coordinator
or superintendent people with expertise
and curriculum instruction and
assessment
um so but I ultimately as the statute
already says RSA 189 colon 1A the school
board has that Authority and that has
that responsibility for at least
overseeing and the governance
responsibility of curriculum standards
delivery of instruction and so forth
within their Community within their
local community
thank you thank you representative
thank you thank you for answering my
question
um I'm more confused now because it
seemed when you first sat down and you
were reading the bits it seemed like you
were saying that these school board was
responsible for how the things were done
you know
how it was taught whatever and that the
the Department of Education and above
that the legislature was responsible for
the
topics the the what was to be taught in
the school board was to determine how it
was to be taught but this bill is a what
to be taught not a how to be taught so
I'm not sure what your objection is sure
thank you thank you for the question
representative I'll try and clarify to
the extent that I may have been unclear
um I'll read again RSA 189 colon 1-8 and
I'll work from there elected school
boards shall be responsible for
establishing the structure
accountability advocacy and delivery of
instruction in each School operated and
governed in its District
to accomplish this end and to support
flexibility in implementing diverse
educational approaches school boards
shall establish in each School operated
and governed in its District
instructional policies and established
instructional goals based upon available
information about the Knowledge and
Skills pupils will need in the future
that's the School Board responsibility
I'm going to jump over to RSA 193-e the
adequate education statute and I'm not
going to read the whole thing this one
gets very long but the the legislature
in response to Claremont in response to
its constitutional obligations and
constitutional mandates under Claremont
states that the this is again RSA
193-e colon 2 Dash little a
uh the specific criteria in substantive
educational program that deliver the
opportunity for an adequate education
shall be defined and identified as the
school approval standards in the
following learning areas English
language arts mathematics science social
studies including civics government
economics so on and so forth Arts
education World languages so the
legislature has defined what a
constitutionally adequate education is
it's these I guess 11 Provisions found
in that statute that I just cited
I'm also going to jump up to
um uh RSA
193-e colon 1 paragraph two respecting
New Hampshire's long tradition of
community involvement it is the purpose
of this chapter to ensure that
appropriate means are established to
provide an adequate education through an
integrated system of shared
responsibility between state and local
government in this system the state
establishes the minimum standards the 11
criteria that I just read and the
minimum standard ZD 306 that are being
under revision from the state board
right now for public school and academic
standards for inclusion and okay I'm
sorry in this system the state
establishes minimum standards for public
school approval and academic standards
for inclusion and delivery of
educational services to the local level
school districts then have the
responsibility and flexibility in
implementing diverse educational
approaches to instruction and curriculum
tailored to meet the needs of students
so From nhsba's perspective the state
has an obligation a constitutional
obligation per Claremont to establish
and Define inadequate education we've
done that in 193 e2a the minimum
standards fill in the gaps how many
credits for for for for graduation What
policies a school board has to adopt
relative to its its obligation under the
minimum standards for public school
approval and to some degree some
criteria relative to what your
mathematics program has to have what
your world language program has to have
however within that traditionally in New
Hampshire anyway the local school boards
have been free to the local school
districts I should say through
collaboration between administrators and
school boards to select their own
curriculum to select their criteria to
select their grading mechanism to select
their competency standards so on and so
forth so and and just to be clear as I
said the the content of what's in here
great you know we wish our our kids
could learn all about all of this the
other thing too we remember there's 180
days of instructional time and the list
of things being added to RSA 189 gets
longer and longer every year and we've
got to find time to teach that not that
it isn't worthy but nhsba's position is
that the state sort of sets the minimum
standards and defines the criteria for
an adequate education and then the local
school boards have the flexibility to
implement that via their own curricular
options standards grading so on and so
forth
further questions represent cordelli
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
Barrett for being here
um based on
um your statements just now in terms of
um 189 versus 193e
et cetera would
um the school boards Association
position be that the
language added several years ago in
relation to the Holocaust and genocide
in 189
was
incorrectly placed in 189 and would have
would would oppose it now as uh it
should be in 193e sir thank you very
much for the question representative I
know I I I'd have to go back and look
and see what our position was on that
bill I think we signed an opposition
um again don't quote me on it I have to
go back and look but I think our
argument was essentially the same that
you know these things should not be the
state should not be dictating to Local
School District specific curricular
components if you are going to do that
nhsba as I said it would be more
palatable if it were in 193e and then
paid for by the state rather than piling
these on in an RSA 189
I'd like to interject just for a second
the state through the legislation that
we passed did put the Holocaust yes
right into 193 e to a under substant
education content of an adequate
education it says social studies
including civics government economics
geography history and Holocaust and
genocide education okay guys we did that
last year oh and I see it also is if I'm
if I'm a chairman LED representative
Cordell it's also still an RSA 18911 as
well too so it's in both places now
I was not aware of that I thought it was
only in 189. no it's under adequacy yeah
okay
further further questions
for the school boards
not seeing you thank you very much thank
you Mr chair yep
are there any more cards for this bill
and that takes us through the hearing
bills for today I would like to have a
caucus of the Republicans here following
I don't coffee
scripture